I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hi, everybody. Hey, you guys. Welcome to safety training. Yeah. It is season three, episode 19, written by BJ Novak and directed by Harold Ramis. Yes. And Jenna, I mean, I'm gonna talk about this as we go. But on the DVD commentary for this episode, there is BJ, Mindy, and Harold Ramis. And it was so wonderful to hear him. Yeah. Oh, I'm gonna go listen to that.
我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正为你们带来终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士们。大家好。嘿，你们好。欢迎来到安全培训。是的。这是第三季第19集，由BJ·诺瓦克编剧，哈罗德·雷米斯执导。没错。珍娜，我的意思是，我们稍后会谈到这一点。但在这一集的DVD评论音轨中，有BJ、敏迪和哈罗德·雷米斯。能听到他的声音真是太棒了。是的。哦，我一定要去听听。
I bet that was amazing. It's a great one. It really is. And I'm gonna sprinkle in some some little nuggets from it. All right, I love it. Let's start with a summary. It is safety training day in The Office. Michael and Dwight are on a mission to illuminate the dangers of the workplace. Meanwhile, Andy returns to The Office after his five weeks of anger management training. And he is determined to make a fresh start with all of the Dunder Mifflin employees. It is a doozy, Jenna. I have no fast facts today. What? I have no fast facts. Should I go buy a lottery ticket? Like what's happening in the universe or things are going to be a big shift? What's going on? First of all, I have a very big thing we
我敢说那一定很棒。这集很精彩。确实如此。我会从中穿插一些小花絮。好的，我喜欢。让我们从剧情摘要开始。《办公室》的安全培训日到了。迈克尔和德怀特肩负着揭示工作场所危险的使命。与此同时，安迪在完成了五周的愤怒管理培训后回到了办公室。他决心与所有邓德·米夫林公司的员工重新开始。这真是个了不起的时刻，珍娜。我今天没有冷知识。什么？我没有冷知识。我是不是该去买张彩票？宇宙中发生了什么，还是会有什么重大转变？怎么回事？首先，我有一件非常重要的事情，我们
have to acknowledge in lieu of fast facts. Oh, what? Lady, today is the one year birthday of office ladies. Get out. Yes. Yes, lady. Our very first episode aired one year ago this week. Oh my God. How I I I'm so bad about putting things in calendars. This is a big deal. This is our one year birthday. It's our one year birthday. Happy birthday to us office ladies, boss ladies podcast. Oh my gosh. And you guys, thank you for being part of our office ladies journey for one whole year. Yes. Oh, wait. Yeah, Sam is tapping on the glass, Sam. I know why. Yes, I wanted to say congratulations for a year. I got you guys these about a year ago when it came up on the podcast and have been waiting patiently
在冷知识之外必须承认。哦，什么？女士，今天是“办公室女士”播客的一周年生日。别开玩笑了。是的，是的，女士。我们的第一集是在一年前的这一周播出的。天哪。我怎么……我真不擅长在日历上记事。这可是件大事。这是我们的一周年生日。是我们的一周年生日。祝我们“办公室女士”、老板女士播客生日快乐。天哪。伙计们，感谢你们一年来一直陪伴着我们的“办公室女士”之旅。是的。哦，等等。是的，山姆在敲玻璃，山姆。我知道为什么。是的，我想说祝贺你们一周年。我大约一年前在播客提到这件事时就给你们买了这些礼物，并一直耐心地等待着
for a reason for you guys to open them. So enjoy. So Angela, we should tell people you're in the studio. Yes. And Sam just handed you a wrapped gift. Yes. I got one at my house. I'm holding mine. Okay, so we're going to open it together at the same time. Open it together. Sam, here we go. I cannot believe you bought this a year ago. It is in. What is it? Well, it's in some Christmas wrapping paper, which I like. I do too. It's got little dogs and sweaters and things. Angela, congrats on one full year of office ladies. Oh, Sam. Oh my God. Oh my God. This is so disturbing. No, Sam. Oh my God. Sam. Sam. Where did you find these? You guys, it's our face as a mask. Amazon. There's now 14 available of each.
一个让你们打开它们的理由。所以，请享受吧。那么安吉拉，我们应该告诉大家你在录音室里。是的。山姆刚刚递给你一份包装好的礼物。是的。我家里也有一个。我正拿着我的。好的，我们要同时一起打开它。一起打开。山姆，我们开始吧。我不敢相信你一年前就买了它。它在……这是什么？好吧，它用了一些圣诞包装纸，我喜欢。我也喜欢。上面有小狗、毛衣之类的图案。安吉拉，祝贺“办公室女士”满一周年。哦，山姆。天哪。天哪。这太令人不安了。不，山姆。天哪。山姆。山姆。你在哪找到这些的？伙计们，这是我们脸的口罩。亚马逊。现在每种还有14个库存。
Oh my Lord. Because you bought one. Oh my gosh. I guess I have to poke out the eyes. Yeah. In a very creepy way, you have to poke the eyes out to wear them. Oh, I don't want to poke my eyes out. Oh, I have to. I just poked my own eyes out. Oh, you did. Okay. I just poached my own eyes out. It's really creepy. Oh yeah. Are you smiling behind your mask, Angela? I am smiling, but I know it's fine. You can't tell. Thank you, Sam. Oh my gosh, Sam. I love it so much. Well, congrats on a year, guys. Wow. Oh, thank you. Oh my gosh. That was so fun. Well, that, I know it wasn't a fast fact, but that was pretty great. Yeah. That was like an office lady's big fact. Yeah. Well, I thought that since
天哪。因为你买了一个。天哪。我想我得把眼睛戳出来。是的。以一种非常诡异的方式，你必须把眼睛戳出来才能戴上它们。哦，我不想戳我的眼睛。哦，我必须这么做。我刚刚戳了我自己的眼睛。哦，你真的做了。好的。我刚刚戳了我自己的眼睛。这真的很诡异。哦，是的。安吉拉，你在面具后面笑吗？我在笑，但我知道这没用。你看不出来。谢谢你，山姆。天哪，山姆。我太喜欢了。好吧，祝贺你们一周年，伙计们。哇。哦，谢谢。天哪。那太有趣了。好吧，我知道那不是冷知识，但那真的很棒。是的。那就像是“办公室女士”的大新闻。是的。好吧，我想既然
it's our birthday in lieu of fast facts, I thought we could just go to our mail bag and answer some frequently asked questions this week. Oh, I love that. Here is a fan question from Eve and Maria Barbic. They said, each time there is a conference room meeting, is everyone given an assigned seat or can you sit where you want? We were always given an assigned seat. We would walk into the conference room and they would usually have a little sticky note on each chair with our name on it. Yeah. And we knew that was our spot because they would plan it out. They would plan the camera blocking and the camera angles and how they were going to catch all of our reactions according to who had dialogue and who didn't.
今天是我们的生日，代替冷知识，我想我们这周可以直接查看我们的邮件袋，回答一些常见问题。哦，我喜欢这个。这是一个来自伊芙和玛丽亚·巴比奇的粉丝提问。她们说，每次有会议室会议时，每个人都有指定的座位，还是可以随便坐？我们总是被指定座位。我们会走进会议室，他们通常会在每把椅子上贴一张写有我们名字的小便利贴。是的。我们知道那是我们的位置，因为他们会提前规划好。他们会规划摄像机的遮挡、拍摄角度，以及根据谁有台词、谁没有台词来捕捉我们所有的反应。
Yeah. So they planned all that out before we even walked in the room. Yeah. Sometimes someone's dialogue would affect someone else and you would need to see their reaction immediately after the line of dialogue. So they had that all mapped out and sometimes if you were really big and pregnant, you were in the back row, just going to say. Yes. So we could hide that big old belly. That's right. We're getting close to that, Ang. To my belly. Yeah. That's next season. I know. That's going to be crazy for me. I can't wait to hear those stories. I'm just going to probably drive you guys all crazy because I'm going to be like, and this one, Isabel was really kicking. I can't wait. I can't wait. We're going to get it
是的。所以他们在我们走进房间之前就规划好了一切。是的。有时某人的台词会影响到另一个人，你需要看到他们在台词后的即时反应。所以他们把这些都安排好了，有时如果你怀孕了，肚子很大，你就会坐在后排，我只是想提一下。是的。这样我们就可以藏起那个大肚子。没错。我们快到那个阶段了，安。我的肚子。是的。那是下一季的事。我知道。对我来说那会很疯狂。我迫不及待想听听那些故事了。我可能会把你们都逼疯，因为我会说，这一集，伊莎贝尔真的在踢我。我等不及了。我等不及了。我们要把这一切
all down on record. What else you got? All right. This question comes from Raisha Patterson. Can you explain the decision of the audience not hearing the questions posed by the documentary crew? So like in our talking heads, right? Yeah. She asked, did Greg Daniels make this decision or was this taken from the BBC version? Well, I mean, I have my thoughts. My thoughts are usually in a documentary. The camera crew wants to disappear. They want to really capture people's lives and they try not to like interfere too much. And so I would guess and I think you probably have the answer that they wanted it that way. They wanted it to really feel like a documentary. Yeah, I reached out to Greg and you are exactly right. He said they
都记录下来。你还有什么？好的。这个问题来自雷莎·帕特森。你能解释一下为什么观众听不到纪录片摄制组提出的问题吗？比如在我们的采访环节，对吧？是的。她问，这是格雷格·丹尼尔斯做的决定，还是借鉴了BBC版本？好吧，我的想法是。我的想法是，通常在纪录片中，摄制组希望消失。他们真的想捕捉人们的生活，尽量不去过多干预。所以我猜，我想你可能知道答案，他们就是想要那种效果。他们希望它真的感觉像一部纪录片。是的，我联系了格雷格，你说得完全正确。他说他们
made the decision because he felt like the audience would be more invested and more connected to our characters if you didn't hear anyone asking the questions. If your mind wasn't thinking about this crew of people filming them. Yeah. But he said they did wonder about this all the time. They wondered about what are the circumstances when they might reveal someone from the crew. And I remember, at least on set, Angela, I don't know if you remember this, but there was this big debate about in the final season or ever, if we reveal who the documentarian is, who's been making this, who should it be? And I remember the cast saying that it should either be Greg Daniels or Ken Quapas. Do you remember this
做出这个决定是因为他觉得，如果你听不到有人在问问题，观众会更投入，与我们的角色联系更紧密。如果你的大脑没有在想这群人在拍摄他们的话。是的。但他确实说他们一直都在考虑这个问题。他们想过在什么情况下可能会揭露摄制组的某个人。我记得，至少在片场，安吉拉，我不知道你是否记得，但当时有一个大争论，就是在最后一季或者任何时候，如果我们揭露纪录片制作者是谁，是谁一直在制作这部片子，那应该是谁？我记得演员们说那应该是格雷格·丹尼尔斯或者肯·夸帕斯。你还记得这个
conversation? I do. I do. And I remember I wanted that. I wanted to see the camera crew. But also, Jenna, I don't know what it's like for you when you watch actual documentaries. I love them. And if I ever hear the voice of like the documentarian like off camera, I'm instantly fascinated. I'm like, okay, I want to see this person. Yeah, you want to see a shot of their face, right? You're like, I've heard a voice. Yeah. Well, Greg told me that there was also some debate that maybe it should be Randall Einhorn or Ricky Gervais. Oh. That like at the very end, it would be revealed that Ricky Gervais was our documentarian. I would like to go one step further and say, what if it was David Brent? Oh, what if David
对话吗？我记得。我记得。我记得我想要那样。我想看到摄制组。但珍娜，我不知道当你观看真正的纪录片时是什么感觉。我喜欢它们。如果我听到像纪录片制作者在镜头外的声音，我会立刻着迷。我会想，好吧，我想看到这个人。是的，你想看到他们的脸，对吧？你会想，我听到了一个声音。是的。好吧，格雷格告诉我，当时也有一些争论，也许应该是兰德尔·艾因霍恩或者瑞奇·热维斯。哦。就像在最后，会揭露瑞奇·热维斯是我们的纪录片制作者。我想更进一步说，如果是大卫·布伦特会怎样？哦，如果是大卫·
Brent had come from the UK to make a documentary in America like his own? Well, I guess there was a problem with this idea because Greg told me that there are a few times that you do hear the voice for the documentarian. And do you know whose voice it is? Ken Quapas. Dave Rogers. Oh, no way. Right. And when Greg told me that, I couldn't even think of any times that we heard the voice. Did he loop it in? Like when did he? Yeah. And I don't know why or when. So we haven't gotten to it, right? Like we haven't heard a documentarian yet so far. So it must be coming up. We're going to have to track it. Oh, wow. I want to track that. These are good. These are good questions. I thought so too. All right. Are
布伦特从英国来到美国制作一部像他自己那样的纪录片呢？好吧，我想这个想法有个问题，因为格雷格告诉我，有几次你确实听到了纪录片制作者的声音。你知道那是谁的声音吗？肯·夸帕斯。戴夫·罗杰斯。哦，不会吧。没错。当格雷格告诉我的时候，我甚至想不出我们听到过声音的任何时候。他后期配音了吗？是什么时候？是的。我不知道为什么或什么时候。所以我们还没到那儿，对吧？我们目前还没听到纪录片制作者的声音。所以那一定是在后面。我们得追踪一下。哦，哇。我想追踪那个。这些问题很好。这些问题很好。我也这么认为。好的。你准备好
you ready for another one? Yeah. All right. This question, we got a lot. This was definitely a most frequently asked. Okay. We got this question from Julianne K, Luke D, Kate Smith, Alana Boylan, and two Emmelies. Okay. The first one is Emily Howard. And the second is my own sister, Emily. You texted me this question. She has been catching up on our podcast, Angela. And it's so funny because I'll just suddenly get a text where she's like, oh my God, you told people I threw up in Ellie's bushes? I know. I know. I know. And I'm like, oh yeah, you're just catching that. Yeah. That happened a while ago. Yeah. My sister, Janet, listens and so does my stepson, Jack. And remember when we did Laundry
回答下一个了吗？是的。好的。这个问题，我们收到了很多。这绝对是最常被问到的问题之一。好的。我们收到了来自朱莉安·K、卢克·D、凯特·史密斯、阿兰娜·博伊兰和两位艾米丽的问题。好的。第一个是艾米丽·霍华德。第二个是我自己的妹妹，艾米丽。你给我发短信问了这个问题。她一直在补我们的播客，安吉拉。这太搞笑了，因为我突然会收到一条短信，她说，天哪，你告诉别人我在艾莉的灌木丛里呕吐了？我知道。我知道。我知道。我说，哦，是的，你刚看到那集啊。是的。那是很久以前的事了。是的。我妹妹珍妮特在听，我继子杰克也在听。还记得我们做“洗衣与背叛”那集吗？是的。杰克戴着耳机从卧室出来说，安吉拉。我说，哎呀，抱歉。我们的孩子没听过我们那样说话。艾米丽问了什么？好的。他们都想知道为什么我们节目里有多个导演，而不是只有一个？这样他就可以为下一个导演做准备，对吧？我的意思是，我实际上给我妹妹打了电话，因为我说，我不知道怎么在短信里解释。我是这样解释的。我说，你知道，拍一集需要一周时间，但导演在前一周准备，后一周剪辑。所以导演的工作是三周长。所以你不可能让一个人导演每一集。那是不可能的。但她说，嗯，
and Betrayal? Yeah. Jack came out of his bedroom with his headphones on and was like, Angela. I was like, oops, sorry. Our kids don't hear us talk like that. What did Emily ask? Okay. They all want to know why do we have multiple directors on the show instead of just one? So he can prep the other one, right? I mean, so I actually called my sister because I was like, I don't know how to put this in a text. And I explained it like this. I said, you know, it takes us one week to shoot an episode, but the director works the week prior preparing it and the week after editing it. So the director's job is three weeks long. So you couldn't have someone direct every single episode. It would just be impossible. But she was like, well,
我不知道，因为有时我看这些流媒体节目，他们全程都是同一个导演。我说，是的，那是因为在那些流媒体节目中，很多时候他们写的是少量的剧本。是六个或八个剧本，他们把它们都写好。然后他们就像拍一部长电影一样拍摄它们。那是真的。他们提前做好所有准备，之后做所有剪辑。他们也会不按顺序拍摄。就像电影一样，他们会拍完一个地点。所以就像是，我们这周要拍完高中所有的场景。是的。下周，我们要拍完房子里的所有场景，他们就像拍电影一样拍摄。
I don't know because sometimes I watch these streaming shows and they have the same director the whole time. And I'm like, yeah, that's because on those streaming shows, a lot of times they've written, it's a short number of scripts. It's six scripts or eight scripts and they write them all. And then they kind of shoot them like one big long movie. That's true. And they do all their prep beforehand and they do all their editing after. And they'll shoot out of order too. They'll like a movie, they will wrap out locations. So it'll be like, we're going to shoot every single scene we have at the high school this week. Yeah. And next week, we're going to shoot every scene at the house and they shoot like a movie.
但在我们的节目中，我们把每一集都拍得像它自己的小电影。所以这就是原因。而且我们拍了24集，而不是6集。没错。而且我们在拍摄时他们还在写剧本。所以是的，这就是为什么我们每集有一个导演，而且他们会轮换。是的。那么安吉拉，这个问题是给你的。这是来自克里斯蒂娜·库兹兰。好的。她说，安吉拉，你能在你的播客里用印尼语说点什么吗？因为我的女儿阿兰娜正在学校学习这门语言。她是这个节目的忠实粉丝，觉得扮演她最喜欢的办公室角色的那个人在印尼长大真是太酷了。好的，阿兰娜，我们说“嗨，你好吗？我很好。谢谢。”好吗，珍娜，我们一起说。
But on our show, we shot each episode like its own little mini movie. So that's why. And we also did like 24 instead of six. Exactly. And they would be writing while we were shooting. So yeah, that's why we have one director per episode and they switch. Yeah. So now Angela, this one comes to you. This is from Christina Kuzland. Okay. And she said this, Angela, can you say something in Indonesian on your podcast? Because my daughter Alana is studying the language in school. She is a big fan of the show and thought it was so cool that the person who played her favorite office character had grown up in Indonesia. All right, Alani, how about we say, hi, how are you? I'm fine. Thank you. Okay, Jenna, we'll do it together.
是的。所以“你好吗”是“Apa kabar”。“Apa kabar, Terima kasih”。我喜欢这个。给你。那只是一个简单的小短语，但我的意思是，我喜欢在印尼长大的时光。我在那里度过了一个非常美好的童年，我有非常美好的回忆。所以谢谢你问那个问题。如果我遇到任何会说印尼语的人，我会非常兴奋。几年前，我在商场，有一对夫妇在鞋子旁边，他们在谈论鞋子。那个男人说，“Waduh mahal sekali”。他的意思是，这些真的很贵。我太兴奋了。我说，“Oh, Anda bicara bahasa Indonesia”。就像，我说，你们会说印尼语。他们看着我
Yes. So how are you is Apakabar. Apakabar, Terima kasih. I love it. There you go. That's just a little simple phrase, but I mean, I loved growing up in Indonesia. I had such a wonderful childhood there and I have very fond memories. So thank you for asking that question. I get really excited if I ever run into anyone that can speak Indonesian. Like years ago, I was at the mall and there was a couple over by a bunch of shoes and they were talking about the shoes. And the man said, waduh mahal sakali. And what he was saying was like, these are really expensive. And I got so excited. And I was like, oh, Andabajara Baja Indonesia. Like, I was like, you guys speak Indonesian. And they looked
就像，什么？然后我们说了印尼语。我真的，我真的很着迷。我真的很兴奋。安吉拉，你会说三种语言，因为你还会说西班牙语。一点点。我听得懂的比说得好，是的。我觉得我理解它比我能说它更好。是的。但我真的很佩服你这一点。我希望我能流利地说另一种语言，但我不会。好吧，你知道，在这段时间里，我一直在用多邻国。我喜欢多邻国。我一直在学习语言。我一直在复习西班牙语，因为我觉得我可能离流利说西班牙语更近了，印尼语很棒，但我在这里没有太多机会使用它。是的。是的。我们不会有很多
at me like, what? And then we spoke Indonesian. I get, I really geek out. I get really excited. Angela, you speak three languages because you also speak Spanish. Un poco. Yo, yo entiendo mas que hablar, si. I feel like I understand it better than I can speak it. Yeah. But I really admire this about you. I wish that I spoke another language fluently and I don't. Well, you know, during this time, I've been doing du lingo. I love du lingo. And I've been language. I've been just brushing up on Spanish because I feel like I could be close, you know, closer to being fluent in Spanish and Indonesian is great, but I don't get a lot of chance to use it here. Yeah. Yeah. We'll get a lot
说它的机会。好吧，谢谢克里斯蒂娜和阿兰娜。我们真的很喜欢那个问题。谢谢你们。谢谢。所以，你知道我们收到很多人的来信，告诉我们《办公室》和这个播客是如何帮助他们度过困难时期的。是的。你们的信件和电子邮件对我们意义重大。我们想今天在这里分享几封。是的。所以，约翰·佩特里写信告诉我们这封美丽的邮件，关于他和他的女儿凯拉在听“办公室女士”时是如何建立联系的，以及这对他的意义。约翰，你的信真的触动了我们的心。噢。好吧，卢克·福特写信提到了他的女儿索菲亚，她有一些健康问题。
of opportunities to speak it. Well, thank you to Christina and Alani. We really liked that question. Thanks guys. Terima kasih. So, and you know that we get a lot of mail from people telling us how much the office and this podcast is helping to get them through tough times. Yeah. And your letters and emails mean a lot to us. And we thought we would share a few here today. Yes. So, John Petrie wrote in to tell us just this beautiful email about how he and his daughter, Kayla, have bonded while listening to Office Ladies and what that has meant to him. And John, your letter really touched our heart. Aw. Well, Luke Foote wrote in about his daughter, Sophia, who is having some health issues.
她是这个节目的忠实粉丝，我们想给她一个小小的问候。嗨，索菲亚。嗨，索菲亚。我们只想说谢谢你的收听，我们很高兴你喜欢这个节目，我们给你送上大大的拥抱。是的。我们也想向伊利诺伊州芒特普罗斯佩克特的朱莉娅问好。朱莉娅，我们希望你早日康复，这样你就能回家陪你的小孩子们了。是的。伙计们，我知道我们以前说过，但我们真的很喜欢每周做这个播客。和你们一起重温这部剧是我们的绝对荣幸。我们喜欢你们的信息。我只是，我感到非常感激能以这种方式建立联系，做这个节目对我们来说也是一件非常特别的事情。
And she's a big fan of the show and we wanted to give her a little shout out. Hi, Sophia. Hi, Sophia. We just want to say thanks for listening and we're so glad you love the show and we're sending you some big hugs. Yes. And we also want to say hello to Julia in Mount Prospect, Illinois. Julia, we hope that you get better soon so you can get home to your little kiddos. Yeah. And guys, I know that we've said this before, but we really love doing this podcast each week. It is our absolute pleasure to rewatch this with you. We love your messages. I just, I feel so grateful to be connected in this way and doing this show has just been a really special thing for us too.
我的意思是，是的，谈到这段时间，和你一起做这件事，珍娜，以及与每周收听的每个人分享，并与你们所有人建立一个社区，我甚至会感到情绪激动。我们只是爱你们。它滋养我们，就像它滋养你们一样。是的。我的意思是，我收到很多信息，安，人们告诉我们，比如，哦，我在开车去上班时听你们的节目，我是个必要工作者，它在工作前真的让我平静下来，或者，你知道，我在家时听。你知道，我在洗衣服，我在听你们的节目。这很有趣，安，因为那就是我听我们节目的时候，你知道，当我们准备做剪辑笔记时，我折叠衣服并听我们
I mean, yeah, I get emotional to even talk about what this time and doing this with you, Jenna, and sharing with everyone that's listening in each week and just having a community with all of you. And we just love you guys. It feeds us as much as it feeds you. Yeah. I mean, I get a lot of messages, Ang, that people tell us like, oh, I'm listening to you while I drive to work and I'm an essential worker and it really calms me down before my job or, you know, I'm listening while I'm home. It's, you know, I'm doing the laundry and I'm listening to you. And it's funny, Ang, because that's when I listen to our episodes, you know, when we get ready to do our edit notes, I fold the laundry and listen to us
的节目。所以我想我真的知道你在说什么。我也做同样的事。哦，女士，我在捡狗屎的时候听过我们的节目。哦，天哪。我没戴耳机听我们，只是不管我在做什么。但我非常喜欢听每个人的故事。是的，这一切都温暖了我的心，你知道吗？这是困难时期。是的。这是困难时期。但我们会一起度过难关的。我们会。我们感谢你们帮助我们度过难关。好吧，听着，我们休息一下吧。好的。然后我们会回来进行一些安全
too. So I'm, I think I know literally what you're talking about. I do the same thing. Oh, lady, I've listened to us while picking up dog poop. Oh boy. I don't have my headphones on listening to us just like whatever it is I'm doing. But I love to hear everyone's story so much. And yeah, it just, it just all of it warms my heart, you know? And it is tough times. It is. It is tough times. But we're going to get through it together. We are. And we thank you guys for helping us get through it. Well, listen, why don't we take a break? Okay. And then we will come back with some safety
培训。好的。好的。所以我们以安迪回到办公室开始这一集。他回来了，他焕然一新。他打算改名叫德鲁。他走到帕姆面前。他拿着一盒东西。珍娜，有两件事我需要开门见山地讨论。好的。第一，在四秒钟时，接待处有一株新植物。
training. All right. All right. So we start this episode with Andy coming back into the office. He's been back and he's new and improved. He's going to go by the name Drew. And he walks up to Pam. He's got a box full of stuff. Jenna, two things I need to discuss right out of the gate. All right. Number one, at four seconds, we have a new plant at reception.
不，我们刚有一株新植物。没关系。帕姆。帕姆显然每周都把它们扔掉。她有什么问题？它甚至在一个新花盆里。这是一个陶瓷花盆。它有点像彩虹，边缘是紫色的。发生了什么？我不知道，安吉拉，但我想说，你知道，有很多事情我们一直在
No, we just had a new plant. It doesn't matter. Pam. Pam throws them out every week, clearly. What is her problem? It's even in a new pot. It's a ceramic pot. It's kind of like a rainbow, like trimmed in like a purple. What's happening? I don't know, Angela, but I want to say, you know, there's a lot of things that we've been
注意到，如果你在互联网上深入挖掘，你会发现很多人都注意到了。我从来没见过这个植物问题被提出来。这是你和这个播客独有的。我知道这听起来很疯狂，但我有个想法，我想抓拍前台的每一株植物，并把它们做成拼贴艺术。是的。然后把它装裱起来，挂在我的办公室里。哦，好的。等等，这是，这是，嗯，这周的，准备好了吗？哦，它，嗯，这个是在一个彩虹条纹的花盆里。我知道。
noticing that then if you deep dive on the internet, you see lots of people have noticed. I have never once seen this plant issue come up. This is exclusive to you and this podcast. I know this sounds crazy, but I had this thought that I wanted to screen grab every single plant at front reception and make collage art out of it. Yeah. And then frame it and I'll hang it in my office. Oh, okay. Wait, here's, here's, um, this week's ready. Oh, it's, uh, this one is in like a rainbow striped pot. I know.
它非常喜庆。我知道。你再也见不到它了。跟它说再见吧。好的。你的另一件事是什么？好吧，我的另一件事是，你知道，安迪/德鲁他的那盒东西。什么东西是用锡纸包着的？看起来像个，那是盘食物吗？是什么？是的。我也看到了。我当时想，谁会那样带午餐？那是他的午餐吗？是的。我，我不知道。我对此很好奇。
It's very festive. I know. You'll never see it again. Say goodbye to it. All right. What was your other thing? Well, my other thing is, you know, Andy slash drew his box of stuff. What is wrapped in tinfoil? It looks like a, is it a plate of food? What is it? Yes. I saw that as well. And I was like, who brings their lunch in like that? Is that his lunch? Yeah. I, I don't know. I was very curious about it.
你知道，当安迪进行采访时，他正在解释他要改一个新名字，他有了一个新态度，他有了一种处理“脾气暴躁”的新方法。你注意到他的采访背景里有多少墙了吗？不，我猜就像，全是墙。几乎没有窗户。然后当镜头切到德怀特的采访，他在谈论他必须回避安迪时，是的，在德怀特的采访中，有很多窗户，墙很少。这只是我注意到的事情。是因为德怀特在这家公司有未来，但安迪没有吗？也许安迪撞墙了？我不知道。我不知道。有很多墙。我只是这么说。
You know, when Andy has his talking head and he's sort of explaining that he's going to go by a new name, he's got a new attitude and he's got a new way to deal with the grumpies. Did you notice how much wall there was in his talking head? No, I guess there's like, it's all wall. There's almost no window. And then when it cuts to Dwight's talking head where he's talking about how he has to shun Andy, yeah, in Dwight's talking head, it's a lot of window and very little wall. It was just something I noticed. Is it because Dwight has a future at this company, but Andy doesn't maybe Andy hit a wall? I don't know. I don't know. There's a lot of wall. That's all I'm saying.
好吧，我确实注意到安迪总是，他就像那种对每件事都有小短语的人，比如他的“精巧礼物”和“脾气暴躁”，还有很多绰号。好吧，我们有一个来自唐·麦克利的粉丝提问，好的，他写信说安迪提到他旧绰号的次数太多了，而且几乎总是不同的。在节目过程中提到了多少个绰号？哦，天哪，这是个好问题。我在节目圣经里查了一下，这是它说的。它们在这里，准备好了吗？Nard Dog，Boner Champ，King Butt，Ice Man，Puke，Ace，Buzz，那些是他上大学时用的。然后在这一集中，他要求每个人叫他德鲁。在下一集中，他给自己起了
Well, I do notice that Andy always, he's like one of these people that has little, little phrases for everything, like his nifty gifties and the grumpies and a lot of nicknames. Well, we had a fan question from Don Mackley, okay, who wrote in to say there are so many times Andy mentions his old nicknames and they're almost always different. How many nicknames were mentioned over the course of the show? Oh my Lord, that's a good question. I looked it up in the show Bible and here is what it says. Here they are, ready? Nard Dog, Boner Champ, King Butt, Ice Man, Puke, Ace, Buzz, those were while he was in college. And then in this episode, he asked everyone to be called Drew. And in the next episode, he gives himself
绰号“Will Do”。所以这些只是安迪的绰号，他自己起的。只是安迪。没错，因为不像他的朋友西兰花罗伯和那些家伙。是的，没错。这些只是安迪自称的名字，比如Boner。所以就是这样。哇。所以那是九个。我数了九个。九个绰号。你小时候有什么绰号吗？你的朋友呢？没有。他们叫我珍娜。哦，天哪。什么？好吧，让我们看看，在大学里。Ham Bone。好吧，那是高中。Ham Bone。我还有个绰号叫Bones，因为我真的很瘦。Ham Bone，Bones。我在大学里。我室友的名字也叫安吉拉。所以他们叫我Kinsey。然后那变成了Kins，Tiny Kins。但我烫了头发，我会
the nickname Will Do. So these are just nicknames for Andy, for himself. Just Andy. Right, because it's not like his friends like Broccoli Rob and all those guys. Yes, that's right. These are just names that Andy has referred to himself as being Boner. So there you go. Wow. So that's nine. I counted nine. Nine nicknames. What were nicknames you had growing up? What about your friends? Just no. They called me Jenna. Oh my gosh. What? Well, let's see, in college. Ham Bone. Well, that was high school. Ham Bone. I was also called Bones because I was really skinny. Ham Bone, Bones. I was in college. My roommate's name was also Angela. So they called me Kinsey. And then that became Kins, Tiny Kins. But I had a perm and I would
把马尾辫扎在头顶上。所以一些人开始叫我Cush Ball。好的。Cush Ball，Ham Bone，Bones，Tiny Kins。很多绰号。你很像安迪。我在为儿童慈爱医院做慈善垒球队时给自己起了一个绰号。请告诉我那是什么。Kinzenator。那在我的球衣上。哦，天哪，我是安迪。发生了什么？我不知道。我的意思是，人们叫我Fisher。他们叫我的姓，但从来不像，从来没觉得那是个正式的绰号。没错。好吧，我朋友曾经告诉我，听着。告诉我这是否触动了你。什么？我的一个朋友去参加了这个非常强烈的，比如在治疗中心的治疗周。
wear a ponytail kind of like on top of my head. So a few people started calling me Cush Ball. Okay. Cush Ball, Ham Bone, Bones, Tiny Kins. A lot of nicknames. You're very Andy Eskins. I gave myself a nickname when I was on a charity softball team for Children's Mercy Hospital. Please tell me what it is. The Kinzenator. That was on my jersey. Oh my God, I'm Andy. What's happening? I don't know. I mean, people called me Fisher. They called me by my last name, but it was never like, it never felt like an official nickname. Right. Well, my friend told me once, listen to this. Tell me if this hits you. What? A friend of mine went and did this very intense, like therapy week at this therapy center.
太棒了。对吧？这就是你应该挖掘任何童年创伤的地方。哦，真的吗？解开你所有的包袱。听起来很可怕。对吧？超级强烈。他告诉我的是，当你到达那里时，你填一张表格，你被问到，你父母小时候叫你什么绰号？那就是他们整个星期称呼你的名字。这应该，我想，试图让你回到一个空间，在那里你会开始解开你所有的包袱。我不想去，因为我不想填任何表格。我受够了表格。好吧，我们知道你这一点。我不想填你的表格。我不想做你的问卷。我很惊讶你有
Great. Right? This is where you're supposed to like dig into any of your childhood traumas. Oh, really? Unpack all your baggage. Sounds horrible. Right? Super intense. What he told me was that when you get there, you fill out a form and you are asked, what is the nickname that your parents called you when you were a child? And that is the name they refer to you as the entire week. And it's supposed to, I think, try to put you like back into a space where you'll start unpacking all your baggage. I don't want to go cause I don't want to fill out any forms. I'm done with forms. Well, we know that about you. I don't want to fill out your form. I don't want to do your questionnaire. I'm surprised you have
护照，因为那需要填一些非常强烈的表格。我知道。而且我上了大学。这么多表格。这么多表格。它们不适合你。我必须做的时候做了。我现在做完了。我做完了。是的。好的。这个强烈的治疗中心因为表格而失去了你。是的。太多表格了。跳过。好的。好吧，我对吉姆有意见。我想我知道那是什么。安迪真的很认真地在执行他从愤怒管理中经历的过程。他试图扭转局面。他告诉吉姆他现在要改名叫德鲁。吉姆说，不，我不会那样叫你。我当时想，真是个混蛋。真是个混蛋。是的。为什么不呢？叫这个家伙德鲁对你有什么损失？他只是在捉弄他
a passport because that was some real intense form filling out. I know. And that I got into college. So many forms. So many forms. They're not for you. I did it when I had to do it. I'm done now. I'm done. Yeah. Okay. This intense therapy place that lost you at forms. Yeah. Too many forms. Pass. Okay. Well, I have a beef with Jim. I think I know what it is. Andy is really earnestly doing his process that he went through from anger management. He's trying to turn things around. He tells Jim he's going to go by Drew now. And Jim goes, no, I'm not going to call you that. And I was like, what a jerk. What a jerk. Yeah. Why not? What does it cost you to call this guy Drew? He's just messing with him
来捉弄他。是的。为什么你要对一个正在努力，你知道，改过自新的人挑衅？是的。在安迪与办公室里的每个人经历不同场景的删除片段中，他受到了考验。他一直很认真，试图度过难关。比如他带了饼干，它们真的很烂，人们在谈论饼干有多烂。他们说，哦，是谁带来的？安迪说，我，但他没有生气。他只是在努力克服它。所以是的，我觉得吉姆在那里有点混蛋。我同意。哦，珍娜，我想回到德怀特的采访，说到表格
to mess with him. Yeah. Why are you being an instigator with a person who's struggling to, you know, turn over a new leaf? Yeah. There is a runner in the deleted scenes of Andy going through different scenarios with everyone in the office where he's tested. And he keeps being earnest and trying to get through them. Like he brought in cookies and they were really crappy and people were talking about how crappy the cookies were. And they're like, oh, who brought him in? And Andy was like, me, but he didn't get mad. He was just like working through it. So yeah, I thought Jim was a little bit of a jerk right there. I agree. Oh, and Jenna, I want to go back to Dwight's talking head speaking of forms
关于你的童年。他会写什么？他从四岁到六岁被回避，因为他没有保存金枪鱼罐头里多余的油。我的意思是，他说这就像用沉默扇人耳光。哎呀。是的。好吧，让我们进入这一集的主线剧情吧。我们开始吧。迈克尔有一个采访，他解释说今天是安全培训日。它将由托比领导。他真的希望托比不会搞砸。没错。但首先，他们都要去仓库听达里尔关于仓库安全的演讲。这会很“Zoppity”。这会很“Zoppity”。你知道，德怀特说，好吧，让我们去
to fill out about your childhood. What would he have written? He was shunned from ages four to six because he didn't save the excess oil from a tuna can. I mean, he said it's like slapping someone with silence. Yeesh. Yeah. Well, let's get in to the main plot of this episode now. Let's do it. Michael has a talking head where he explains that today is safety training day. And it's going to be led by Toby. He really hopes Toby isn't going to mess it up. Right. But first, they're all going to go down to the warehouse and listen to Daryl's presentation about safety in the warehouse. It's going to be zoppity. It's going to be zoppity. You know, Dwight is like, all right, let's get down to the
仓库吧，对吧？每个人都排队走下走廊。有一个我喜欢的删除片段。那只是一个快速片段。但这些就是我喜欢我们节目的地方。德怀特说，大家，找个伙伴。他为什么要那样说？我正走在走廊上，梅雷迪思落后我一两步。德怀特说，大家，找个伙伴。安吉拉·马丁抓住了梅雷迪思的手，梅雷迪思说，别抓我的手。那只有三秒钟。我只是喜欢它。我喜欢它。太搞笑了。就像你不是在从大楼撤离。你只是要去仓库。我知道，但不管德怀特在做什么，我都想，我加入了。好的，找个伙伴。好吧，当我们到达
warehouse, right? Everyone's like filing down the hallway. There is a deleted scene that I loved. It's just a quick snippet. But these are the things I loved about our show. Dwight is saying, everybody, buddy up. Like, why is he saying that? And I'm walking down the hallway and Meredith is like a step or two behind me. And Dwight's like, everyone, buddy up. And Angela Martin grabs Meredith's hand and Meredith is like, don't hold my freaking hand. And it's like three seconds. And I just loved it. I love that. It's so funny. It's like you're not evacuating from the building. You're just going to the warehouse. I know, but whatever Dwight is doing, I'm like, I'm on board. Okay, buddy up. Well, when we get
仓库时，这些是我有史以来最喜欢的场景，由克雷格·罗宾逊领导。哦，天哪，我喜欢克雷格发言的时候。我喜欢他负责，迈克尔必须听他的时候。他只是试图传达重要的信息。是的。他必须应付迈克尔。你知道，这让我想起了看我的小学一年级学生上课。哦，试图让人们专注于任务。是的。老师说，三加二等于几？每个人都说，我有一只新小狗。外面很吵。我妈妈喜欢葡萄酒。老师说，三加二等于几？这就是它让我想起的样子。达里尔试图和我们所有人谈论这台叉车和打包机。是的。
down to the warehouse, these are some of my favorite scenes of all time led by Craig Robinson. Oh, man, I love it when Craig has the floor. I love it when he's in charge and Michael has to listen to him. He is just trying to deliver information that is important. Yes. And he has to deal with Michael. You know, it reminds me very much of watching my first graders assume classes. Oh, trying to keep people on task. Yes. The teacher is like, what is three plus two? And everyone's like, I got a new puppy. It's loud outside. My mom likes wine. And the teacher is like, what is three plus two? This is what it reminds me of. Darryl trying to talk to all of us about this forklift and this Baylor. Yeah.
你知道，哈罗德·雷米斯谈到了克雷格，谈到他认为他是一位多么出色的演员，以及他觉得克雷格是一位自然主义的演员。就像这从他口中说出的台词是如此自然，以至于你全心全意地相信他。它看起来从不像是写好的，对吧？就像他节奏的一切，就像这一切，它是如此，它是惊人的。是的。我当时在研究那个。哈罗德·雷米斯那样说太搞笑了，因为我当时在研究，就像，他是怎么让它看起来那么自然的？我的意思是，克雷格真的很棒，伙计们。他超级有才华。克雷格，来参加播客吧。我联系了他。我们交换了一些信息。这会发生的。我们只需要确定日期。
You know, Harold Ramis talked about Craig and about how brilliant of an actor he thought he was and how he felt like Craig was a naturalistic actor. Like it was so natural, this dialogue coming out of him that you just wholeheartedly believe him. It never seemed scripted, right? Like everything about his cadence, like all of it, it's so, it is, it's amazing. Yeah. I was sort of studying that. That's so funny that Harold Ramis said that because I was studying that was like, how does he make it seem so natural? I mean, Craig is really brilliant guys. He's super talented. Craig, come be on the podcast. I reached out to him. We've traded some messages. It's going to happen. We just have to figure out dates.
让我们锁定它，克雷格。让我们锁定它。好吧，当达里尔解释打包机的危险时，例如，迈克尔开了许多玩笑。安迪试图讨好德怀特，这就是人们开始打赌的时候，对吧？是的。这是整集的另一个故事情节。所以达里尔正要说，你知道每年有多少人在打包机里失去一只手臂吗？凯文和吉姆决定打赌他们认为答案是什么。是的，没错。它发生在四分钟左右。我想和你分享敏迪在DVD评论中说的一些让我真正发笑的话。她说在编剧室里，他们谈论这个打包机，他们真的把它看作是一台可怕的大机器。
Let's lock it up, Craig. Let's lock it up. Well, as Darryl is explaining the dangers of the Baylor, for example, Michael is making a ton of jokes. Andy's trying to suck up to Dwight and this is when people start making bets, right? Yes. This is the other storyline of the whole episode. So Darryl is about to say, do you know how many people lose an arm in a Baylor each year? Kevin and Jim decide to bet on what they think the answer is. Yes, exactly. It happens around four minutes. I want to share with you that Mindy said something that really made me laugh in the DVD commentary. She said that in the writer's room, they were talking about this Baylor and they really saw it as a scary big piece of machinery.
也许它有刀片之类的东西，当他们得到它时，她说它看起来就像一个大电话亭。是的。移动得非常慢。好吧，我和肯特·萨博纳克谈过这个打包机，他说那是一台真正工作的打包机。是的。我们进行了一次真正的安全会议。还记得吗，珍娜，当我们进入仓库拍摄时，我们的第二助理导演举行了一次安全会议，就像，伙计们，我们有一台叉车。我们有一台打包机。什么都不要碰。是的，这些是真正的机器。他说他给制造商Olympic Wire and Equipment打了电话，他们捐赠了一台打包机，因为他们获得了免费的产品植入，所以我们得到了一台免费的打包机。好吧，我想说在
Maybe it had blades or something and when they got it, she said it just looked like a big telephone booth. Yes. That moved really slowly. Well, I talked to Kent Sabornak about this Baylor and he said that it was a real working Baylor. Yeah. We had an actual safety meeting. Remember, Jenna, when we went into the warehouse to shoot, our second AD held a safety meeting that was like, guys, we have a forklift. We have a Baylor. Do not touch anything. Yeah, these are real machines. He said that he called the manufacturer Olympic Wire and Equipment and they donated a Baylor because they got free product placement so that we got a free Baylor. Well, I want to say that there is this little part at the
打包机对话结束时有这么一小部分，它一直在继续，对吧？是的。达里尔说，那么，你明白了吗？迈克尔说，是的，只有在极少数情况下。达里尔说，在任何情况下都没有，在任何情况下都没有。我必须在剧本里查一下，我会告诉你那不在剧本里。我认为那是即兴创作。我觉得我也记得那个，当时在那里，我们只是让史蒂夫和克雷格来回交流。继续。让我们来回交流。它带我回去了，安吉拉。我只是喜欢拍摄这一集，部分原因是，如果你注意到，我们几乎一直都在这些大团体场景中。是的。这是一集大团体场景，不仅如此，我们还
end of the Baylor conversation where it's going on and on, right? Yeah. Darrell is like, so do you understand? And Michael is like, yes, only on the rarest occasion. Darrell is like, on no occasions, on no occasions. I had to look that up in the script and I will tell you that was not in the script. I think that was improvised. I feel like I remember that too, being there and we just let Steve and Craig go back and forth. Just keep going. Let's go back and forth. It brought me back, Angela. I just loved shooting this episode and part of it was because, if you notice, we're all in these big group scenes almost all the time. Yeah. This was an episode of big group scenes and not just that, we also
有机会和帕特里斯、克雷格和卡莉一起工作。我们也有所有的仓库员工。我们一直都在一起。这真的很罕见。我的意思是，它发生在篮球那一集，它发生在这一集，一些圣诞派对之类的事情，但它很罕见，我们都会玩得很开心。我也喜欢它，因为它是一个如此简单的想法。这只是安全培训日。就是这样。它脱轨了，我们都参与其中，就像我们所有人现在都在这辆过山车上。什么工作都做不了。是的。好吧，我必须说，在我们离开现场之前，我绝对喜欢迈克尔记不住马奇的名字。他记不住。不。他叫她Patch，Pudge。他记不住她的名字。我妈妈
got to work with Patrice and Craig and Carly. We had all the warehouse folks too. We were all together all the time. It really is rare. I mean, it happened in the basketball episode, it happened in this one, some Christmas parties and things like that, but it was rare and we would all just have a great time. And I liked it too because it was such a simple idea. It's just safety training day. That's it. And it goes off the rails and we're all in, like all of us are now on this roller coaster. Can't get any work done. Yeah. Well, I have to say, before we leave the scene, I absolutely love that Michael cannot remember Madge's name. He can't. No. He calls her Patch, Pudge. He cannot remember her name. My mom
记不住一个稍微不同的名字，只是稍微不同。这是一个例子。我在大学时，我室友男朋友的名字叫巴特，B-A-R-T Bart。我见到他的那天，我妈妈和我在一起，他一说，嗨，我是巴特。我想，不，不会发生的。不。永远不会记对那个。她叫他什么？多年来。多年来，她叫他Mart。Mart怎么样？Mart。我说，妈，是巴特。我说什么？你说Mart。我说了吗？是的，你说了。哇。谁会给他们的孩子起名叫Mart？我不知道。我不知道，但谁会给他们的孩子起名叫Patch或Patch或Pudge？你说得太对了。顺便说一句，我提前为我们名叫Mart的听众道歉。我也
cannot remember a name that is just slightly different, just slightly different. Here's an example. When I was in college, my roommate's boyfriend's name was Bart, B-A-R-T Bart. And the day I met him, my mom was with me and the minute he was like, hi, I'm Bart. I thought, nope, not going to happen. Nope. It's never going to get that one. What did she call him? For years. For years, she called him Mart. How's Mart? Mart. I'm like, Mom, it's Bart. What'd I say? You said Mart. I did? Yes, you did. Wow. Who would name their child Mart? I don't know. I don't know, but like who would name their kid Patch or Patch or Pudge? You're so right. By the way, I apologize in advance for our listener named Mart. I would also
想向任何名叫Patch或Pudge的人道歉。好吧，现在我们要上楼了，安吉拉。托比要教他的安全会议。不管什么原因，迈克尔强迫仓库里的每个人都来参加这个演讲。保罗·利伯斯坦把这个演得太棒了。就像达里尔在仓库里一样棒，保罗作为托比在办公室里也一样棒。是的。他准备好的事情清单，伙计们。你们准备好听了吗？托比的办公室安全培训，腕管综合症，血液循环不良，电脑屏幕，眼睛疲劳，你可能想带一件毛衣或开衫，以防有穿堂风。是的。迈克尔太沮丧了。他受不了了。这些事情都没有得到你的那么令人兴奋
like to apologize to anyone named Patch or Pudge. Well, now we're going to go upstairs, Angela. Toby is going to teach his safety meeting. For whatever reason, Michael has forced everyone from the warehouse to come to this presentation. Paul Lieberstein knocks this out of the park. As great as Daryl was in the warehouse, Paul is as Toby in the office. Yes. His list of things, guys, to be prepared for. Are you ready for them? Toby's office safety training, carpal tunnel syndrome, poor circulation, computer screen, eye strain, and you might want to keep a sweater or a cardigan in case it gets drafty. Yeah. Michael is so frustrated. He can't take it. None of these things are as exciting as getting your
我想向所有叫Patch或Pudge的人道歉。好了，现在我们要上楼了，安吉拉。托比要开始他的安全会议了。不管出于什么原因，迈克尔强迫仓库里的每个人都来参加这次演讲。保罗·利伯斯坦这次表现得太棒了。达里尔在仓库里有多棒，保罗在办公室里演托比就有多棒。是的。他准备的那些东西，伙计们，准备好了吗？托比的办公室安全培训，腕管综合症，血液循环不良，电脑屏幕，眼睛疲劳，你可能想准备一件毛衣或开衫，以防有穿堂风。是的。迈克尔太沮丧了。他受不了了。这些东西都没有让你
arm cut off in a bailer. He can't take it. He can't take it. At five minutes, 52 seconds, Ryan says, what about a long sleeve tee? Yeah. Here's a great story about that. According to BJ, there was a huge joke debate about that line. What about a long sleeve tee? And at 2 a.m. in the writer's room, they were debating it. Mike Scherr said, no, this is a ridiculous line. And Greg was all for it. This is so funny that they spent time debating this line. I know. I know. I love this line. Me too. And it gets called back later when we're asked to go downstairs. I know. I love it. Well, maybe that's why BJ delivered it. So Riley is because it got in. He knew the backstory of this debate in the writer's room
手臂被打包机切断了。他受不了了。他受不了了。在5分52秒时，瑞安说，长袖T恤怎么样？是的。关于这个有个很棒的故事。据BJ说，关于那句台词有一场巨大的笑话辩论。长袖T恤怎么样？在凌晨2点的编剧室里，他们还在争论。迈克·舒尔说，不，这句台词太荒谬了。而格雷格完全支持。他们花时间争论这句台词真是太搞笑了。我知道。我知道。我喜欢这句台词。我也是。而且后来我们被要求下楼时，它又被呼应了。我知道。我喜欢它。好吧，也许这就是为什么BJ把它说出来的原因。所以莱利是因为它被采纳了。他知道编剧室里关于那句台词的背景故事。
over that line. We had a fan question about another line in this little bit. Okay. Sarah Bell, Dagny Albano and Katie Boyd all asked when Michael's reading the safety booklet and he says office life causes a sedimentary lifestyle. Was that improv or was that in the script? That was not in the script. You're kidding. There's a little bit of banter there between Michael and Toby that looked like it veered a little bit off script. Like they were having a little fun with it. Oh, I love that. So Michael has had it. He takes over. He's like, Toby, I'm going to do the safety training. And he wants to show the warehouse people that working in an office is just as dangerous. And he says, oh, there's seasonal
我们收到一个粉丝关于这一小段中另一句台词的问题。好的。莎拉·贝尔、达格尼·阿尔巴诺和凯蒂·博伊德都问，当迈克尔在读安全手册时，他说办公室生活会导致久坐不动的生活方式。那是即兴发挥还是剧本里的？那不在剧本里。你在开玩笑吧。迈克尔和托比之间有一点玩笑，看起来有点偏离了剧本。就像他们玩得很开心一样。哦，我喜欢那个。所以迈克尔受够了。他接管了。他说，托比，我要做安全培训。他想向仓库的人展示在办公室工作同样危险。他说，哦，有季节性
affective disorder. Like dim light can lead to depression. And the warehouse people, they're out. They're like, yeah, dim lights, a bitch, you live a little sweet, nerfy life, sitting on your biscuit, never having to risk it. And Michael is, he's just so bummed out. He really wanted to prove to these guys that things get just as crazy up in the office. It's such a weird thing to take a stand on. I know. It's such a, it's such a Michael Scott thing to become so invested in this. He just wants to be cool, Jenna. He's fascinated by the warehouse guys. Oh, he really is. And this tracks from previous episodes. And he especially wants them to think he's cool. Yeah, he wants to win their favor. Yeah. Well,
情感障碍。比如昏暗的灯光会导致抑郁。而仓库的人，他们不买账。他们说，是的，昏暗的灯光真糟糕，你过着甜蜜、舒适的生活，坐在你的饼干上，从不需要冒险。而迈克尔，他真的很沮丧。他真的很想向这些人证明办公室里的事情也同样疯狂。坚持这个立场真是太奇怪了。我知道。这太像迈克尔·斯科特会投入其中的事情了。他只是想变酷，珍娜。他被仓库的人迷住了。哦，他确实是。这可以追溯到之前的剧集。他特别希望他们认为他很酷。是的，他想赢得他们的好感。是的。好吧，
now Kevin, Jim, Oscar and Karen are all gathered around Pam's desk. And for whatever reason, they are trying to guess how many jelly beans are in her little dispenser. Yeah, it's now taken over this whole sort of betting from the warehouse. It's how they're going to pass their day. Jim wins. Jim thought 50. Karen went with 51. Turns out there were 49. Yeah. And then at eight minutes, 39 seconds, Kevin says, it's not fair because Jim has spent countless hours talking to Pam at front reception. I mean, hours and hours. Yeah. Oh, awkward. I would like you guys to know that I kept Pam's candy dispenser when we wrapped. What? You're just now telling us this? One year we've been doing this podcast. One year we've
现在凯文、吉姆、奥斯卡和凯伦都围在帕姆的办公桌旁。不管出于什么原因，他们都在试图猜她的小分配器里有多少颗软糖。是的，这现在已经接管了仓库里那种赌博。这就是他们打发时间的方式。吉姆赢了。吉姆猜50。凯伦猜51。结果是49。是的。然后在8分39秒时，凯文说，这不公平，因为吉姆花无数个小时在前台和帕姆聊天。我是说，几个小时又几个小时。是的。哦，尴尬。我想让你们知道，当我们杀青时，我留下了帕姆的糖果分配器。什么？你现在才告诉我们？我们做这个播客已经一年了。一年了，我们
talked about what did you take from set? Yeah. Where is it? I have it. It's in my office. It's a little plastic. It's so simple. I know. And it has a little like silver scooper. And it has a little lid you lift up. Mm-hmm. Yeah. Do you keep candy? Yeah. And people never use the silver scooper. What they would do is they would just open it and shake it into their hand, which by the way, was just a sanitary and effective. But I always use the silver scooper because I'm a big fan of tiny cutlery. You're also a big fan of desserts that come in a very small size. With a very tiny spoon. Yeah. You'd love that. I like eating with tiny cutlery. Do you follow Tiny Kitchen? Yes, from Taste Made. Yes. Where they make
谈论过你从片场带走了什么？是的。它在哪？我有它。它在我的办公室里。它是一个小塑料制品。它太简单了。我知道。它有一个像银色的小勺子。还有一个你可以掀开的小盖子。嗯哼。是的。你放糖果吗？是的。人们从不使用那个银色的小勺子。他们会做的是，他们只是打开它，把它摇进手里，顺便说一句，这同样卫生且有效。但我总是用那个银色的小勺子，因为我是微型餐具的忠实粉丝。你也是非常小尺寸甜点的忠实粉丝。用一把非常小的勺子。是的。你会喜欢的。我喜欢用微型餐具吃东西。你关注“微型厨房”吗？是的，来自Taste Made。是的。他们制作
a teeny tiny meal in a teeny tiny kitchen. Yes. It's mesmerizing. It's mesmerizing. I did a really fun project with Taste Made with my husband, Josh, and we got to go tour the Tiny Kitchen. Jenna, are you there? I can't speak. Are you okay? I can't speak. I thought you froze. I didn't freeze. I can't believe that you got to see the Tiny Kitchen in person. Oh my God. It's so cool. It's so cool. Is it so tiny? It's so tiny. And the lady that does it. The little bitty spatula. The little. She like makes the little egg on the little bay pan. Yes. And, and you know, the oven, they put a little tiny like candle, a little tea. What do they call tea, tea lights? What are they called? Yeah, like a tea candle.
在微型厨房里做一顿微型餐。是的。这太迷人了。这太迷人了。我和我丈夫乔什一起做了一个非常有趣的项目，我们得以去参观微型厨房。珍娜，你在那吗？我说不出话来。你还好吗？我说不出话来。我以为你冻住了。我没有冻住。我不敢相信你竟然能亲眼看到微型厨房。哦，天哪。太酷了。太酷了。它真的很小吗？它真的很小。还有那个做它的女士。那个小小的抹刀。那个小的。她就像在那个小煎锅上做那个小鸡蛋。是的。而且，你知道，烤箱，他们放了一个小小的像蜡烛一样的东西，一个小茶。他们叫什么茶，茶灯？它们叫什么？是的，像茶蜡烛。
Tea candle. Tea candle. They, they do, they really do cook things on the stove pot and they use a little candle. You need to go see it. You'll love it. You guys, it's so cute. Look up the one where they make a little hamburger. Oh. All right. Where were we? I don't know. We got completely lost talking about tiny cutlery and tiny kitchens. I know where we are. Michael has called Pam into her office to ask her opinion on the seriousness of depression versus the threat of working with a Baylor. Yeah. Yeah. I got very excited about this conversation, Jenna, because I thought it was a fantastic, very subtle callback to the convict because Pam says, you know what? The warehouse guys had visuals on their side.
茶蜡烛。茶蜡烛。他们，他们确实在炉灶上煮东西，他们用一个小蜡烛。你需要去看看。你会喜欢的。伙计们，太可爱了。去看看他们做小汉堡的那一个。哦。好吧。我们刚才说到哪了？我不知道。我们完全迷失在谈论微型餐具和微型厨房里了。我知道我们在哪。迈克尔把帕姆叫进她的办公室，询问她关于抑郁症的严重性与使用打包机的威胁的看法。是的。是的。我对这次谈话感到非常兴奋，珍娜，因为我认为这是一个非常精彩、非常微妙的对《罪犯》一集的呼应，因为帕姆说，你知道吗？仓库的人有视觉辅助工具。
Oh my gosh. Light bulb for Michael. If you could look at his face, he's okay at nine minutes, 17 seconds. Look at Steve's face as Michael when he's like, yeah, you're so right. That's all that was missing. That's all that was missing. Yeah. Remember, we learned in the convict from the deleted scene that hoot, the owl came to his school and in that moment, he realized if you want people to hear you, you have to have a costume. You have to have some props. You have to have visual aids. Well, Michael is off and running now. Now he calls Dwight into his office and he's like, we need ways to illustrate the imminent threat of depression faced by office workers. And okay, I am pretty sure all of
哦，天哪。迈克尔的灯泡亮了。如果你能看到他的脸，他在9分17秒时还好。看看史蒂夫作为迈克尔的脸，当他说，是的，你说得太对了。这就是缺少的全部。这就是缺少的全部。是的。记住，我们在《罪犯》的删减片段中了解到，猫头鹰胡特去了他的学校，在那一刻，他意识到如果你想让人听你说话，你必须有服装。你必须有一些道具。你必须有视觉辅助工具。好吧，迈克尔现在出发了。现在他把德怀特叫进他的办公室，他说，我们需要方法来展示办公室员工面临的迫在眉睫的抑郁威胁。而且好吧，我非常确定所有这些
this was either improv or like given to them on the day because this scene in the script is about four lines long. But here, when Dwight suggests a quilt, a depression, Michael says a depression quilt. Michael is like, there's no time to sew one. That is the greatest response. It's not like, no, that's a bad idea. It's like, yes, if only we had time, that would be perfect. I think this was a lot of improv because there's also extra in the deleted scenes. They go on and on. Oh, is it so good? It's fun. It's really fun. And Michael has Dwight's so worked up like Dwight is so immediately on board. Yes. I love the line when he says when Michael says, you know what our killer is? And Michael says depression and Dwight
要么是即兴发挥，要么是当天给他们的，因为剧本里的这一幕只有四行长。但是在这里，当德怀特建议做一床被子，一床抑郁被子时，迈克尔说一床抑郁被子。迈克尔说，没时间缝一床了。那是最好的回应。它不像，不，那是个坏主意。它就像，是的，如果我们有时间，那将是完美的。我认为这有很多即兴发挥，因为删减片段里还有额外的内容。他们没完没了。哦，太好了吗？很有趣。真的很有趣。迈克尔让德怀特如此激动，德怀特立刻就加入了。是的。我喜欢当他说，当迈克尔说，你知道我们的杀手是什么吗？迈克尔说抑郁症，而德怀特
says wolves. Yes. That made me laugh out loud. Oh my gosh. Those two together are so brilliant. Well now we go to the parking lot where Michael is bouncing on a trampoline. He had Dwight reach out to the giant big boy toy store. I looked up, there isn't one just so you know. Oh, okay, that was made up. Well, what I love is the detail in the background of the box and all the packaging that's in the background. Oh, that's a great detail. Yeah. So this came in a box and they had to assemble it. He's going to go up on the roof and he's going to have Dwight call everyone outside. And then he is going to pretend to jump off the roof as a way of illustrating what can happen if your depression goes unchecked. And it
说狼。是的。那让我大声笑了出来。哦，天哪。他们两个在一起真是太棒了。好吧，现在我们去停车场，迈克尔正在蹦床上跳。他让德怀特联系了那个巨大的大男孩玩具店。我查过了，你知道，根本没有那家店。哦，好吧，那是编出来的。好吧，我喜欢的是背景中盒子的细节和背景中所有的包装。哦，那是个很棒的细节。是的。所以这是装在一个盒子里来的，他们必须组装它。他要上屋顶，他要让德怀特把大家都叫到外面。然后他要假装从屋顶跳下去，以此作为展示如果你的抑郁症不加控制会发生什么的一种方式。而且它
was a way to visually teach everyone. That's right. And after he jumps off the roof, he's going to take a few extra bounces just for fun before he walks around the corner to reveal that he is alive, that he's fine. This is, this is Michael's big plan. This is going to show everyone what could go wrong. I have a little nugget here from Harold Ramis. I'm going to share it with you. So they talked about in the commentary that originally the idea was that everyone went up on the roof to talk Michael out of this. Everyone. Yeah. And Harold was like, I don't think it really sells how serious, like what he's contemplating. I think if he's on the roof and he's shouting down to everyone in the parking lot and you
是一种向大家直观教学的方式。没错。在他从屋顶跳下后，他会多跳几下，只是为了好玩，然后他会绕过拐角，揭示他还活着，他很好。这就是，这就是迈克尔的大计划。这将向大家展示可能出错的地方。我这里有一个来自哈罗德·雷米斯的小金块。我要和你分享。所以他们在评论中谈到，最初的想法是每个人都上屋顶去劝说迈克尔放弃这个念头。每个人。是的。哈罗德说，我不认为这真的能体现出他正在考虑的事情有多严重。我想如果他在屋顶上，对着停车场里的每个人大喊大叫，而你
have that whip camera panning from the roof back to him and down and up, you really get the sense of what a horrible idea this is. Yeah. That was Harold. Harold was like, no guys, everyone else should be in the parking lot. Only Michael on the roof. I just thought that was really great. Well, I know that they probably wanted us up on the roof because technically it would be easier to shoot with sound and camera. It was, it was such a technically difficult episode. And I remember that. I remember how difficult it was for them to get angles on all of us and him and the bright sun and the sound kudos to our crew because it doesn't seem like it was difficult, but it was actually really technically difficult.
有那个从屋顶扫回他身上，然后向下又向上的快速镜头，你真的能感觉到这是一个多么糟糕的主意。是的。那是哈罗德。哈罗德说，不，伙计们，其他人都应该在停车场。只有迈克尔在屋顶上。我只是觉得那真的很棒。好吧，我知道他们可能想让我们上屋顶，因为从技术上讲，用声音和摄像机拍摄会更容易。这，这真的是一个技术上很困难的剧集。我记得那个。我记得他们要捕捉我们所有人、他、明亮的阳光和声音的角度有多困难，向我们的剧组致敬，因为看起来并不困难，但实际上在技术上非常困难。
Yeah. And to Steve and the guys that were on the roof, just the limited crew up there with him, they were up on that roof for a really long time. Yeah. Yeah, they were. Well, now back in the office, the whole betting game is still going. People are placing bets on how long it's going to take Kelly to explain to Ryan how Netflix works. They're betting like how many times she's going to say the word awesome and what movie she mentions and how long it takes. It's, it's heated. Yes. We find out that Kelly talked for two minutes and 42 seconds. She said the word awesome 12 times and mentioned six romantic comedies and never had a clue as people were like putting money on the table next to Ryan. Well, we
是的。对于史蒂夫和屋顶上的那些人，只有有限的剧组人员和他在一起，他们在那个屋顶上待了很长时间。是的。是的，他们待了很久。好吧，现在回到办公室，整个赌博游戏还在继续。人们在打赌凯利向瑞安解释Netflix是如何运作需要多长时间。他们打赌她会说多少次“太棒了”这个词，她提到了什么电影，以及花了多长时间。这，这很激烈。是的。我们发现凯利说了两分42秒。她说了12次“太棒了”，提到了六部浪漫喜剧，而且当人们在瑞安旁边把钱放在桌子上时，她根本不知道。好吧，我们
had a fan question from Elizabeth Myers who says old tech alert. Can you guys explain this Netflix scene? What is a queue? Oh, what is a queue? You guys. Yes. I didn't even think of that. Netflix. You remember old Netflix, right, Angela? Yeah, yeah, yeah, you'd put it in your queue like it was like a list of what you were going to watch because you got a DVD in the mail. Yeah. It didn't just come up on your TV. So you would have to go to the Netflix website and pick what DVDs you want them to send to you and you could pick the order. And then when you were done watching it, you put it in this like prepaid postage envelope and you sent it back. And whenever they got the one that you sent back, they
收到一个来自伊丽莎白·迈尔斯的粉丝问题，她说旧技术警报。你们能解释一下这个Netflix场景吗？什么是队列？哦，什么是队列？伙计们。是的。我甚至没想过那个。Netflix。你记得旧的Netflix，对吧，安吉拉？是的，是的，是的，你会把它放进你的队列里，就像它是你打算看的东西的列表，因为你通过邮件收到了一张DVD。是的。它不会直接出现在你的电视上。所以你必须去Netflix网站，挑选你想要他们寄给你的DVD，你可以选择顺序。然后当你看完它时，你把它放进这个预付邮资的信封里，然后把它寄回去。每当他们收到你寄回的那一张时，他们
would send you the next one in your queue. Yeah, it was like a mail in blockbuster, basically. It was revolutionary because the idea was you didn't have to drive to the video store anymore to rent your videos. The problem was though, sometimes you'd be like waiting for your next thing to come up in your queue. Yeah. So lady, this whole Netflix queue thing, it reminded me of how my parents got the DVD mail Netflix service. Yeah. For like ever, for like ever, they would not switch to the streaming one. Why? Why wouldn't they switch? I don't know, but they did the DVD thing forever. And I texted them about it. I had to know and their responses were so funny and my mom said I could share them. Okay. So you said,
就会寄给你队列里的下一张。是的，它基本上就像一个邮寄版的百视达。它是革命性的，因为想法是你不再需要开车去录像带店租录像带了。但问题是，有时你会等待你的下一件东西出现在你的队列里。是的。所以女士，这个整个Netflix队列的事情，让我想起了我父母是如何获得DVD邮寄Netflix服务的。是的。就像永远，就像永远，他们就是不换成流媒体服务。为什么？他们为什么不换？我不知道，但他们永远都在用DVD。我给他们发短信问了这件事。我必须知道，他们的回复太搞笑了，我妈妈说我可以分享它们。好的。所以你说，
what did you wait? What did you text them? I texted, Hey guys, how long ago did you switch from the old Netflix service of getting physical DVDs in the mail to getting the streaming service? Okay. They texted me back separately. Okay. Okay. My dad texted me back. Don't remember quite a while. Okay. The end. My mom texted back, Dad's mowing the lawn, but I think I can help you. Maybe that's why his text was so brief. Yeah, I think so. It made me laugh. Okay. And then she said a while back, I was having lunch with a friend and she told me that we could get Netflix, the cable channel for 9.95 a month. We were paying that just to get two movies a month in the mail. So that's when we signed up and dropped
你等了什么？你给他们发了什么短信？我发短信说，嘿伙计们，你们多久以前从通过邮件获取实体DVD的旧Netflix服务切换到获取流媒体服务的？好的。他们分别给我回了短信。好的。好的。我爸爸给我回了短信。不记得了，有一段时间了。好的。结束。我妈妈回短信说，爸爸在割草，但我认为我可以帮你。也许这就是为什么他的短信那么简短。是的，我想是这样。这让我笑了。好的。然后她说，前段时间，我和一个朋友吃午饭，她告诉我我们可以以每月9.95美元的价格获得Netflix，那个有线电视频道。我们当时付那么多钱只是为了每月在邮件里收到两部电影。所以那时我们注册并取消了
our other plan. It's funny because I had wanted to get Netflix on cable, but dad kept telling me it was too expensive. I mean, you know how dad is about money. So we've had Netflix streaming for I'd say three years now, but dad does not like it when you have to pay extra for certain movies. I really want to watch the movie Fatima, but you have to pay for it and he won't do it. But I will once again win this battle. You know how it works. Oh my gosh. That is so layered. That is so jam packed with information. First of all, I love that she's like, dad is mowing. Then I love that she's like a few, a while back I was having lunch because you're like, wait, what? Where are we going? What's happening?
我们的其他计划。这很有趣，因为我一直想在有线电视上获得Netflix，但爸爸一直告诉我它太贵了。我是说，你知道爸爸对钱的态度。所以我们有Netflix流媒体大概三年了，但爸爸不喜欢你必须为某些电影额外付费。我真的很想看《法蒂玛》这部电影，但你必须付费，而他不会这么做。但我会再次赢得这场战斗。你知道它是怎么运作的。哦，天哪。这太有层次了。这充满了信息。首先，我喜欢她说爸爸在割草。然后我喜欢她说前段时间我吃午饭，因为你会想，等等，什么？我们要去哪？发生了什么？
I know. I know. But yes. So I guess three years, only three years ago, my parents were still getting DVDs in the mail. And I remember because I would ask them, you know, I would be like how they were in love with Downton Abbey, Downton Abbey. And I'd be like, what season are you on? And they're like, well, we're waiting for the next season. It hasn't come yet. Yes, it's right there. Just subscribe. It's right there. Oh my gosh. They're waiting for their DVD. That is that is amazing. All right. Should we take a break and then come back and talk about those watermelons on the roof? Yes. And I have some good info from Kentopedia about the watermelons. Well, I want to hear it. All right, good. We'll be right
我知道。我知道。但是是的。所以我猜三年，仅仅三年前，我父母还在通过邮件接收DVD。我记得是因为我会问他们，你知道，我会问他们他们有多喜欢《唐顿庄园》，《唐顿庄园》。我会问，你们看到哪一季了？他们说，嗯，我们在等下一季。它还没来。是的，它就在那儿。订阅就行了。它就在那儿。哦，天哪。他们在等他们的DVD。这，这太神奇了。好吧，我们休息一下，然后回来谈谈屋顶上的那些西瓜？是的。而且我有一些来自肯托百科关于西瓜的好信息。好吧，我想听听。好的，好的。我们马上
back. All right. So we are back Dwight and Michael are on the roof and they are testing sort of an experiment to see how far Michael has to jump out to land on the trampoline. And they've got some watermelons and they're giving it a go. So lady, I reached out to Kentopedia because I had two questions. Okay. Number one, I wanted to know how did Steve and Rain get up on the roof and who all was up there with them? Did they have to ride that thing that you and John rode? Yes, they had to use that big scissor lift and everyone had to wear a safety harness. But here was some something new that Kent added this season. What Kent hired some stunt guys to rig safety cable up on the roof of the stage so that
回来。好的。所以我们回来了，德怀特和迈克尔在屋顶上，他们正在进行某种实验，看看迈克尔必须跳多远才能落在蹦床上。他们有一些西瓜，他们正在尝试。所以女士，我联系了肯托百科，因为我有两个问题。好的。第一，我想知道史蒂夫和雷恩是怎么上屋顶的，还有谁和他们在一起？他们必须坐你和约翰坐的那个东西吗？是的，他们必须使用那个大型剪叉式升降机，每个人都必须穿安全带。但这是肯特本季增加的一些新东西。肯特雇了一些特技演员在舞台屋顶上安装安全绳，这样
if there was ever a time where the crew had to be up there to do lighting, they would be able to wear a safety harness and clip themselves onto a safety cable. So for this scene, Steve and Rain and Randall, who was our cinematographer, they all had safety harnesses underneath their costumes and they were clipped onto the safety cable as well. So that also probably involved the wardrobe department because she would have had to have made sure their suits were big enough to go over the safety harness. Yes, I also had a question about the watermelons. Oh, okay. And I was not alone. Lauren Brightwell, Megan Keele, Ciara Begley, Phoebe Bono, and Maddie McKee all wanted to know how many watermelons were
如果剧组人员必须上去做灯光，他们将能够穿上安全带并将自己扣在安全绳上。所以对于这一幕，史蒂夫、雷恩和我们的摄影师兰德尔，他们都在服装下穿了安全带，而且他们也被扣在了安全绳上。所以这也可能涉及服装部门，因为她必须确保他们的西装足够大，能穿在安全带外面。是的，我还有一个关于西瓜的问题。哦，好的。而且我并不孤单。劳伦·布莱特韦尔、梅根·基尔、西亚拉·贝格利、菲比·博诺和麦迪·麦基都想知道有多少个西瓜
used for the trampoline test scene. How many? Kent told me that we purchased 12 watermelons, but around take 10, Kent said to Harold Ramis, I think we're going to need to CGI the watermelon thing because none of the watermelons that he was throwing off the roof were coming anywhere close to hitting the car. Yeah, they talk about it in the commentary that they weren't getting it until take number 11. Oh, Kent said it was the last watermelon, that it was take 12. Oh, Harold Ramis said it was take number 11. Oh, well, so guys, it was either take 11 or 12, I guess by some miracle, it landed on the trampoline and it hit the car perfectly. And I feel like Steve and Rainne's expression like is real because they were
被用于蹦床测试场景。多少个？肯特告诉我我们买了12个西瓜，但在第10次拍摄左右，肯特对哈罗德·雷米斯说，我想我们需要用CGI制作西瓜的部分，因为他从屋顶扔下来的西瓜没有一个接近击中汽车。是的，他们在评论中谈到，直到第11次拍摄他们才成功。哦，肯特说是最后一个西瓜，那是第12次拍摄。哦，哈罗德·雷米斯说是第11次拍摄。哦，好吧，所以伙计们，要么是第11次要么是第12次，我想奇迹般地，它落在了蹦床上，并且完美地击中了汽车。而且我觉得史蒂夫和雷恩的表情是真实的，因为他们
like, oh my God, we finally did it. Well, do you know what this reminded me of, Angela? This reminded me of those Dude Perfect guys. Do you know Dude Perfect? No, what's Dude Perfect? Okay, so this is my son is obsessed with Dude Perfect. Is this like a basketball like you have to shoot a basketball from a crazy place? Yes, they are these guys, they're from Texas, and they became famous by doing all of these elaborate trick shots. Yes, on YouTube. But I mean, they're so much bigger now, they've got like a live tour now and, you know, yada, yada, but yes, they would have done something like this, they would have thrown a watermelon off of a building onto a trampoline and tried to hit something
就像，哦，天哪，我们终于做到了。好吧，你知道这让我想起了什么吗，安吉拉？这让我想起了那些“完美伙计”们。你知道“完美伙计”吗？不，什么是“完美伙计”？好的，所以我儿子沉迷于“完美伙计”。这就像篮球一样，你必须从一个疯狂的地方投篮吗？是的，他们是这些家伙，他们来自德克萨斯州，他们通过做所有这些精心设计的技巧投篮而出名。是的，在YouTube上。但我的意思是，他们现在大多了，他们现在有现场巡演，而且，你知道，等等等等，但是的，他们会做这样的事情，他们会把西瓜从建筑物上扔到蹦床上，并试图击中某样东西
with it. And Dwight and Michael's reaction just 100% reminded me of these Dude Perfect videos that I've been watching with my son. Yes, I have seen those videos, I didn't know the guy's name or whatever they go by, but yeah, our kids love that stuff. It also made me think that maybe we need to collaborate with Dude Perfect on some sort of a frothing thing. So it's like off the tree, hit the trash can. Yeah, for all things trick shots with Office Ladies and Dude Perfect. It's a collaboration we've all been waiting for. And Waffle Ball. How'd you say it just now? You said it in the middle. Waffle Ball. You're rubbing off on me. I know, I love it. Two things before we leave. The whole watermelon
用它。而德怀特和迈克尔的反应100%让我想起了我一直在和我儿子看的这些“完美伙计”视频。是的，我看过那些视频，我不知道那个家伙的名字或者他们叫什么，但是的，我们的孩子喜欢那些东西。这也让我想到也许我们需要与“完美伙计”合作进行某种泡沫化的事情。所以就像从树上掉下来，击中垃圾桶。是的，为了“办公室女孩”和“完美伙计”的所有技巧投篮。这是我们一直在等待的合作。还有华夫球。你刚才怎么说的？你在中间说的。华夫球。你正在影响我。我知道，我喜欢它。在我们离开之前有两件事。整个西瓜
off the roof moment, Jenna. Okay. Number one, all of these shots up here, when they look out over to the trampoline, you can see a great view of the impound lot across the street with all the trains. I noticed it too. Yeah, you get a real slice of where we were, guys. Those were our neighbors when we filmed at Chandler Valley Studios. Yeah. And one last thing from this watermelon moment because I just thought it was so sweet. BJ in the commentary said that this was one of those moments, Jenna. It reminded me of when you talk about being on the roof, eating that grilled cheese sandwich on that warm, beautiful night, right? It was like that for BJ. He said, I had this moment where I was like, wait a second. I'm on a
从屋顶掉下来的时刻，珍娜。好的。第一，所有这些上面的镜头，当他们看向蹦床时，你可以看到街对面扣押场和所有火车的绝佳视野。我也注意到了。是的，你们得到了我们所在位置的真实片段，伙计们。当我们拍摄钱德勒谷工作室时，那是我们的邻居。是的。还有关于这个西瓜时刻的最后一件事，因为我觉得它太甜了。BJ在评论中说这是那些时刻之一，珍娜。这让我想起了当你谈论在屋顶上，在那个温暖、美丽的夜晚吃那个烤奶酪三明治的时候，对吧？对BJ来说就像那样。他说，我有过那一刻，当时我想，等一下。我在一个
roof with Steve Carell and Rainn Wilson and Harold Ramis. We're throwing watermelons and I'm getting paid. Yes. I thought that was so sweet. That's what made me think of the Dude Perfect thing because I was like, these are like a bunch of dudes up on a roof throwing watermelons down, just having a great time, but oh, they're at work. Yeah. Like that was their job that day. I mean, how fun. So fun. Well, I have some more news about the scene before we move on. Okay. The car that they hit was a rental. It was a Chrysler 300 picture car. Guess how much money it cost them to do this gag? Oh my gosh, I don't know how much. They dented the roof and they broke the electric moon roof of the car. From that
屋顶上，和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔、雷恩·威尔逊和哈罗德·雷米斯在一起。我们在扔西瓜，而且我还在拿工资。是的。我觉得那太甜了。这就是让我想起“完美伙计”的事情，因为我想，这就像一群伙计在屋顶上往下扔西瓜，玩得很开心，但哦，他们在工作。是的。就像那是他们那天的工作。我是说，多有趣。太有趣了。好吧，在我们继续之前，我还有更多关于这一幕的消息。好的。他们击中的那辆车是租来的。那是一辆克莱斯勒300道具车。猜猜他们花多少钱做这个恶作剧？哦，天哪，我不知道多少钱。他们弄凹了车顶，还弄坏了车的电动天窗。从那个
one watermelon? Yeah, it cost $6,500 to fix it. Dang. Yeah. All right, should we move back inside? Yes, because I texted Creed Bratton about this next scene. The bedding is continuing on. Everyone is watching Creed eat his apple. Creed doesn't know they're all standing behind him. He sets the apple down. Jim walks by puts a potato where the apple was. Will Creed notice he's now eating a potato and not an apple? Well, we got mail about this, Angela. Bianca H, Kayla O, Cassidy Price, Deanna Horn, and Merilee S all asked, did Creed really take a bite out of a potato? Yeah, I texted him. This is what he said. He wrote, I definitely bit right into that potato and it wasn't half bad. Oh, so there you go. There you go. Well,
一个西瓜？是的，修理它花了6500美元。该死。是的。好吧，我们应该回到里面吗？是的，因为我给克里德·布拉顿发了关于下一幕的短信。赌博还在继续。每个人都在看克里德吃他的苹果。克里德不知道他们都站在他身后。他放下苹果。吉姆走过去，在苹果所在的地方放了一个土豆。克里德会注意到他现在吃的是土豆而不是苹果吗？好吧，我们收到了关于这个的邮件，安吉拉。比安卡·H、凯拉·O、卡西迪·普莱斯、迪安娜·霍恩和梅里利·S都问，克里德真的咬了一口土豆吗？是的，我给他发了短信。这是他说的。他写道，我确实直接咬了那个土豆，而且味道还不错。哦，所以就是这样。就是这样。好吧，
Angela, it makes sense to me because in French, the word for apple is pomme and the word for potato is pomme de terre, which means apple of the earth or apple of the ground. I'm sorry, what is your logic? It makes sense to you that Creed would eat a potato and not know it wasn't an apple because it's the French word is pomme de terre. Yeah, okay. Potato in Indonesian is kintang. What's apple? Apple is apel. Oh, well, the French have related the apple and the potato in their language. Okay. And so, perhaps, perhaps they, I don't know, they're onto something. Perhaps Creed would do well in France. Yeah, I guess that's right. But as long as he doesn't try to pick them up himself at a market. And thump them.
安吉拉，这对我来说很有道理，因为在法语中，苹果的词是“pomme”，而土豆的词是“pomme de terre”，意思是大地之苹果或地面之苹果。对不起，你的逻辑是什么？对你来说有道理，克里德会吃一个土豆而不知道它不是苹果，因为法语词是“pomme de terre”。是的，好的。印度尼西亚语中的土豆是“kintang”。苹果是什么？苹果是“apel”。哦，好吧，法国人在他们的语言中把苹果和土豆联系起来了。好的。所以，也许，也许他们，我不知道，他们发现了什么。也许克里德在法国会做得很好。是的，我想那是对的。但只要他不尝试在市场上自己挑选它们。然后敲打它们。
Before we leave the whole Creed betting scene, at 12 minutes 38 seconds, you can see Angela sitting at her desk watching everyone and judging. Oh, she's not participating, guys. She's not going to gamble. She's not going to bet on things. No. I remember I had a whole conversation with Harold about it, like, where would Angela be in the bullpen? Would she be watching, you know, and she's reluctantly glancing over to see what the hubbub is about, but she will not participate. Well, Angela is a little bit of a busy body in the sense that she likes to know the goings on. But that doesn't mean she's participating. No, she needs to know just enough to judge you, but not enough to be judged.
在我们离开整个克里德赌博场景之前，在12分38秒，你可以看到安吉拉坐在她的办公桌前看着每个人并评判。哦，她没有参与，伙计们。她不会去赌博。她不会去打赌。不。我记得我和哈罗德谈过这件事，比如，安吉拉会在牛栏区哪里？她会看吗，你知道，她不情愿地瞥了一眼看看发生了什么骚动，但她不会参与。好吧，安吉拉在某种意义上是一个有点爱管闲事的人，因为她喜欢知道发生的事情。但这并不意味着她在参与。不，她需要知道的足够多来评判你，但不足以被评判。
Correct. Well, now we get to a scene that is really fun. Dwight has to enlist Andy's help in getting a bouncy castle, which means he has to momentarily unshun him, which leads to a great shun, unshun bit. It's actually unshun, reshun. That's what he says, unshun, reshun. And on the commentary, they talked about this, this little bit and they said that Jean and Lee came up with the whole shun thing and that rain is who physicalized it. Rain doing that hand thing up and down was just rain playing around. I loved that. I know it really sold it. It really did. This like weird, like fake window thing that he was doing. I know. I know. So childish. Okay. So now we go back up on the roof. They have
正确。好吧，现在我们到了一个非常有趣的场景。德怀特必须争取安迪的帮助来弄到一个充气城堡，这意味着他必须暂时解除对他的排斥，这导致了一个伟大的排斥、解除排斥的片段。实际上是解除排斥、重新排斥。这就是他说的，解除排斥、重新排斥。在评论中，他们谈到了这个，这个小片段，他们说吉恩和李想出了整个排斥的事情，而雷恩是将其身体化的人。雷恩上下做那个手势只是雷恩在玩耍。我喜欢那个。我知道它真的卖座。它确实做到了。这个像奇怪的、像假窗户的东西他在做。我知道。我知道。太幼稚了。好的。所以现在我们回到屋顶上。他们有
this bouncy house castle. They're, you know, this is going to be so much better than the trampoline. But then Dwight's like, do you want to test it? And Michael's like, no, no, these tests are going horrible. I won't do it if I keep, if we keep doing these tests. Yes. And he asked Dwight to kind of psych him up, right? And so rain starts doing this amazing musical like thing. It's like the thing that he does when he's pumping himself up in the stairwell before a big sales call or before a big interview. It's the Dwight Eric guitar. Yes. Oh, it's so good. I watched it like three times. Yeah. I loved at the end when he started to like get his like two things with his mouth. It was kind of gross
这个充气城堡。他们，你知道，这会比蹦床好得多。但后来德怀特说，你想测试一下吗？迈克尔说，不，不，这些测试太糟糕了。如果我继续，如果我们继续做这些测试，我就不会做了。是的。他让德怀特激励他，对吧？所以雷恩开始做这种惊人的音乐般的事情。这就像他在大销售电话或大面试前在楼梯间激励自己时做的事情。那是德怀特·埃里克吉他。是的。哦，太好了。我看了大概三遍。是的。我喜欢最后当他开始像用嘴做那两个东西时。那有点恶心
when he was like, yeah. Well, I noticed something Angela. It was very windy in this scene. Did you notice that? Yeah, I did. And I, their ties were like just whipping all around. Did you see that? Yeah. Well, I decided to pause at 14 minutes 30 seconds and read the label on Steve's tie. Oh, you're crazy. And I love it. What'd you find? It looks like it was a tie made by Gianfranco Ruffini, who was an Italian clothing designer. Okay. And the reason I became sort of obsessed with this was because I recently had a conversation with Carrie Bennett, our wardrobe designer. Yeah. And she told me about how when she was designing the show, she wanted every man in the office to have a very specific tie story.
当他像那样时，是的。好吧，我注意到了什么，安吉拉。这一幕风很大。你注意到了吗？是的，我注意到了。而且我，他们的领带就像在到处乱甩。你看到了吗？是的。好吧，我决定在14分30秒暂停并阅读史蒂夫领带上的标签。哦，你疯了。而且我喜欢它。你发现了什么？看起来那是一条由吉安弗兰科·鲁菲尼制作的领带，他是一位意大利服装设计师。好的。我之所以变得有点沉迷于此，是因为我最近和我们的服装设计师凯莉·贝内特谈过。是的。她告诉我关于她在设计这部剧时，她希望办公室里的每个男人都有一个非常具体的领带故事。
She wrote a tie story for every man. And she told me that this was because, you know, when you're designing a show where there's a bunch of men working in an office, it's really hard to differentiate them. It's just a bunch of people in suits and ties. So she told me that when she was doing the original design for the show, she got really worried that all the men were going to look alike because they were all just wearing suits or shirts and ties, right? So by doing this tie story, this was her answer. Her tie story for Michael Scott was that Michael buys all of his suits at JC Penney and they come with a matching tie. So he buys all his clothing as a full kit. And this tie is part of a suit kit. I looked it up.
她为每个男人写了一个领带故事。她告诉我这是因为，你知道，当你设计一部有一群男人在办公室工作的剧时，很难区分他们。这只是一群穿西装打领带的人。所以她告诉我，当她在做这部剧的原始设计时，她非常担心所有的男人看起来都会一样，因为他们都只是穿着西装或衬衫和领带，对吧？所以通过做这个领带故事，这是她的答案。她为迈克尔·斯科特设计的领带故事是迈克尔在杰西·潘尼购买他所有的西装，它们都配有配套的领带。所以他把所有的衣服都作为全套购买。而这条领带是西装套件的一部分。我查过了。
And I think this is like Michael's designer. This is Michael's stuff. That's his go-to guy at JC Penney's. Oh, I'm sorry. Jacques Penay is my Aunt Brenda used to say. Oh, is that how she says JC Penney? Yeah, she'd be like, are we going to go to Tarjay and then Jacques Penay? I love that. I love that. Well, I don't think you can get these guys' suits anymore because when I was trying to find them online, the only place I could find them was Etsy and eBay, people reselling them if you want a Michael Scott tie. Incidentally, something I thought was interesting, the tie maker's son is named Remo Rafini and he's a billionaire. What's Remo doing? How do you get to be a billionaire? He is also a fashion designer
而且我认为这就像迈克尔的设计师。这是迈克尔的东西。那是他在杰西·潘尼的首选。哦，对不起。我阿姨布伦达过去常说“雅克·佩内”。哦，那是她怎么说杰西·潘尼的吗？是的，她会说，我们要去“塔杰”然后去“雅克·佩内”吗？我喜欢那个。我喜欢那个。好吧，我不认为你还能买到这些家伙的西装，因为当我试图在网上找到它们时，我唯一能找到的地方是Etsy和eBay，人们在转售它们，如果你想要一条迈克尔·斯科特的领带。顺便说一句，我觉得有趣的一件事，领带制造商的儿子叫雷莫·拉菲尼，他是个亿万富翁。雷莫在做什么？你怎么成为亿万富翁的？他也是一位时装设计师
and he is the owner of this huge fashion company in Italy. In Italy. There you go. There you go. All because they were filming on a windy day. I went down that rabbit hole. I love that. I love that. I love that all the men have their tie story. You certainly see that. I feel like with Andy because he's so New England preppy. I feel like his suit looks very different from the other fellas. Yeah. Okay. Well, we can discuss more tie stories as they become relevant in future episodes. I hope we do. I'm going to hold you to that, you and Carrie. Carrie should send in some audio clips. Oh, yes. I'll have her do that. Okay. Or maybe we should have her on for a deep dive because she has fascinating stories. Oh, I would love that. I would love it. Okay. Well, now Dwight
而且他是意大利这家大型时装公司的老板。在意大利。就是这样。就是这样。全都是因为他们在刮风的日子拍摄。我掉进了那个兔子洞。我喜欢那个。我喜欢所有的男人都有他们的领带故事。你当然看到了。我觉得安迪因为他太像新英格兰预科生了。我觉得他的西装看起来和其他伙计们很不一样。是的。好的。好吧，我们可以在未来的剧集中讨论更多的领带故事。我希望我们能。我会让你信守诺言的，你和凯莉。凯莉应该寄一些音频片段来。哦，是的。我会让她那样做的。好的。或者也许我们应该让她来做一个深入的探讨，因为她有迷人的故事。哦，我会喜欢的。我会喜欢的。好的。好吧，现在德怀特
burst into the office, right? He tells everyone, come outside, come outside. Michael is suffering from depression and you need to come out here. Everyone begins to ask him, are we going to need a coat? He's like, no, the weather, it's a gorgeous day out. Come on, come on. And then he has a line at 15, 15 minutes, one second that I absolutely love because he's like, Dwight, he's being Dwight, come on, come on. And then he answers Stanley and he goes, no, no, it really is. It's, it's very nice. That was so rain. It was so rain. It was so good. I loved it too. I loved it. So now everyone gets up and they go outside to see what's happening with Michael. Yeah. And we had a fan question from Caitlin Moribito and Brinkley Hope who said,
冲进办公室，对吧？他告诉大家，到外面来，到外面来。迈克尔患有抑郁症，你们需要到这里来。每个人都开始问他，我们需要穿外套吗？他说，不，天气，外面是美好的一天。来吧，来吧。然后他在15分15秒有一句我非常喜欢的台词，因为他就像，德怀特，他正在做德怀特，来吧，来吧。然后他回答斯坦利，他说，不，不，真的，天气很好。那太雷恩了。那太雷恩了。太好了。我也喜欢它。我喜欢它。所以现在每个人都起来，他们到外面去看迈克尔发生了什么。是的。我们收到一个来自凯特琳·莫里比托和布林克利·霍普的粉丝问题，他们说，
when the office workers go down to watch Michael demonstrate depression, some people are in the elevator and other people are coming down the stairs, but they arrive at the same time. So I guess like they noticed it doesn't matter if you took the stairs of the elevator. And they said, we imagine this is because they all couldn't fit in the elevator at the same time, especially because it's not a real elevator. But the question is, how would they decide who was on the elevator and who was coming down the stairs? And which did we prefer waiting in the elevator or being crammed in the stairwell for the start of the scene? I always liked the stairwell because that elevator is small and it always made me feel a
当办公室员工下楼去看迈克尔演示抑郁症时，有些人坐电梯，有些人走楼梯，但他们同时到达。所以我猜他们注意到你走楼梯还是电梯并不重要。他们说，我们想象这是因为他们不能同时挤进电梯，特别是因为它不是一个真正的电梯。但问题是，他们如何决定谁坐电梯，谁走楼梯？我们更喜欢哪种，在电梯里等还是在楼梯间里挤着开始这一幕？我一直喜欢楼梯间，因为那个电梯很小，它总是让我感到一点幽闭恐惧症。一样。如果可以选择，我会投票走楼梯。但走楼梯，你必须走很多，然后下来。所以你确实必须上下，因为你必须绕到楼梯后面，你知道，拐角后面。所以现在我们在停车场，每个人都聚集在一起。迈克尔在屋顶上。这就是迈克尔和德怀特开始他们的表演的时候。哦，是的，他们排练得很好。在我们进入那个之前，珍娜，我想让你知道哈罗德说这个停车场里有太多东西他们不得不剪掉，他有一个更长的版本，他非常喜欢，真正得到了每个人对正在发生的事情的反应。他在DVD评论中说，他
little claustrophobic. Same. I would always, if given the choice, I would vote stairs. But with the stairs, you would have to go up quite a bit and come down. So you did have to go up and down, up because you'd have to tuck around behind the stair, you know, behind the corner. So now we're in the parking lot and everyone has gathered. Michael is up on the roof. And this is when Michael and Dwight kind of start their show. Oh, yeah, they have it very rehearsed. Before we get into that, Jenna, I want you to know that Harold said that there was so much from all of this parking lot that they had to cut, that he had a longer version that he just loved that really got everyone's reactions to what was happening. And he said in the DVD commentary, he
就像，我希望那个我们拥有的原始更长剪辑，你们有一天都能看到。它在删减片段里吗？不，我想还有更多东西。删减片段里有一些，但我认为还有更多甚至没有进入删减片段。哇。我知道，我知道。好吧，我们收到一个来自泰丝·肖尼克的粉丝问题。好的。这是她写的。经过53小时的分娩和包括全身麻醉的紧急剖腹产后，我醒来时抱着我的第一个女儿。我说的第一句话是“德怀特，你这个无知的荡妇”。来吧。她说这是因为我醒来时听到我丈夫告诉护士她应该看《办公室》。所以我必须知道那句台词是从哪里来的？
was like, I hope that original longer cut that we had that you guys will all get to see it someday. And is it in the deleted scenes? No, I think there's even stuff. There's some in the deleted scenes, but I think there's more that didn't even make the deleted scenes. Wow. I know, I know. Well, we had a fan question from Tess Shornick. Okay. This is what she wrote. After 53 hours of labor and an emergency C section that included general anesthesia, I woke up holding my first born daughter. And the first thing I said was Dwight, you ignorant slut. Come on. She said this was because I woke up to hearing my husband tell the nurse about how she should watch the office. So I have to know where did that line come from?
是的。哦，天哪，我喜欢这句台词。你们重看时这句台词在15分37秒。好吧，这是基于丹·艾克罗伊德和简·柯廷的《周六夜现场》的一个小品。他们会做这个《60分钟》观点反观点的模仿。简·柯廷扮演自由派，丹·艾克罗伊德扮演保守派。它的运作方式是简·柯廷先陈述她的立场。然后丹·艾克罗伊德会以“简，你这个无知的荡妇”开头。然后他会给出他的反驳观点，简·柯廷会说，“丹，你这个自大的混蛋”。这就是这个片段。所以这是迈克尔再次从《周六夜现场》偷东西来做他的小表演。还有《周六夜现场》在那个时候
Yes. Oh my gosh, I love this line. This line for you guys rewatching is at 15 minutes, 37 seconds. Well, this was based on a skit from Saturday Night Live with Dan Ackroyd and Jane Curtin. They would do this parody of the 60 minutes point counterpoint. And Jane Curtin played a liberal, and Dan Ackroyd played a conservative. And what the way it would go is like Jane Curtin, she would present her side first. And then Dan Ackroyd would lead off with Jane, you ignorant slut. And then he would give his counterpoint and Jane Curtin would say, Dan, you pompous ass. And this was this bit. So this is Michael once again, stealing from Saturday Night Live for his little show. And also Saturday Night Live in a time when
哈罗德·雷米斯认识所有那些人，你不得不怀疑，对吧？对。我喜欢那个。我喜欢那个。我在很多东西上都看到过那个短语。我在抱枕、袜子、钥匙扣、棒球帽上看到过它。是的。这是一个经典。所以迈克尔和德怀特，是的，他们正在做某种表演，你知道，他们有它，显然他们排练过这个。每个人都开始在停车场谈论，这是真的吗？不是真的吗？它可能绝对不是真的。他们开始打赌。凯文让每个人都动起来。是的，凯文说，如果有人给你一万比一的赔率赌任何事情，你就接受它。如果约翰·梅伦坎普赢得了奥斯卡，凯文将成为一个非常富有的人。
Harold Ramis knew all those folks, you have to wonder, right? Right. I love that. I love that. I've seen that phrase on so many things. I've seen it on throw pillows, on socks, keychains, baseball hats. Yeah. It's a classic. So Michael and Dwight, yes, they're doing sort of this performance, you know, they've got it, clearly they have rehearsed this. And everyone starts talking in the parking lot, like, is this real? Is it not real? It probably definitely is not real. And they start taking bets on it. Kevin gets everyone going. Yeah, Kevin says, if someone gives you 10,000 to one odds on anything, you take it. And if John Mellon Camp ever wins an Oscar, Kevin's going to be a very rich dude.
哈罗德·雷米斯认识所有那些人，你不得不感到好奇，对吧？没错。我喜欢这个。我喜欢这个。我在很多东西上都见过这句话。我在靠垫、袜子、钥匙扣、棒球帽上都见过。是的。这是经典。所以迈克尔和德怀特，是的，他们正在进行某种表演，你知道，他们已经准备好了，显然他们排练过。大家开始在停车场议论，这是真的吗？不是真的吗？这大概率肯定不是真的。他们开始为此打赌。凯文带动了所有人。是的，凯文说，如果有人给你一万比一的赔率赌任何事情，你都要接受。如果约翰·梅伦坎普真的赢得了奥斯卡奖，凯文就会成为一个非常有钱的人。
You go Kev. You go Kev. Well, my favorite part of this, Angela, is when Michael realizes that the warehouse guys aren't there. Those are the ones he wants to impress the most. He doesn't care about doing this for his co-workers upstairs. The whole point of this, and he gets so frustrated with Dwight, is that the warehouse guys see that he's on the roof. Yes. So he gets Dwight to bring all the warehouse folks out and they start the whole thing over again. And this is when you realize it is 100% scripted. He says, Dwight, you ignorant slut again. Yeah, Dwight does his air quotes with his fingers again. Yes, exactly. And Jim has this great talking head where he's like, the first performance was a little rough,
凯文，你上。凯文，你上。安吉拉，我最喜欢的部分是迈克尔意识到仓库的人不在的时候。那些是他最想打动的人。他根本不在乎楼上的同事怎么看。这件事的重点，也是他对比怀特感到如此沮丧的原因，是仓库的人得看到他在屋顶上。是的。所以他让怀特把仓库的人都叫出来，然后他们又重新演了一遍。这时候你就会意识到这百分之百是照着剧本演的。他又说了那句“怀特，你这个无知的荡妇”。是的，怀特又用手指做了引号的手势。没错，正是这样。吉姆有一个很棒的访谈镜头，他说，第一次表演有点生疏，
but, you know, they hit their stride and he can't wait to bring his parents tomorrow for the matinee. Yeah, it's just been great. Then we see Creed coming out of the bushes. He's zipping up his pants. Like, I guess he's just gone pee, which is so on brand for Creed that he just went over to the bushes to take a whiz with his co-workers right there. Anyway, he says, guys, what's up with the bouncy castle? And they're like, what? They all run over. And this is the moment where Jim and Pam are like, Oh my God. Oh my God. He's, it's part of this bit. He's going to do it. Well, lady, I remember shooting this scene because it is not in the script that Creed comes around the corner zipping up his pants. And we came up with that on the day. We thought it would be really
但是，你知道，他们渐入佳境，他迫不及待想明天带他父母来看日场演出。是的，这真是太棒了。然后我们看到克里德从灌木丛里出来。他在拉裤子拉链。我想他大概是去撒尿了，这非常符合克里德的风格，他就在同事面前跑到灌木丛里去撒尿。总之，他说，伙计们，那个充气城堡是怎么回事？他们说，什么？他们都跑了过去。这就是吉姆和帕姆心想，天哪，天哪，他要演了，这是他戏份的一部分。好吧，女士，我记得拍摄这一幕，因为剧本里并没有写克里德拉着裤子拉链从拐角处走出来。这是我们当天想出来的。我们觉得这会非常
funny that Creed was taking a leak. And that's how he discovered bushes. And that's how he discovers it. Because it was like, well, why is Creed around the corner? And we're like, in the moment you realize like, how, oh wait, how do we justify that Creed went behind the bushes? And that I, I, we thought that was so funny. We thought that was so Creed. So I loved that. And then I also loved that Pam tells Michael that he has to come down because she has a present for him. And he never doesn't believe her. Well, you know, Jenna, I found it interesting because when I was watching this again, all I could think of is where's Karen? Like Jim and Pam are sort of together in this moment. They're figuring
有趣，克里德是在撒尿。他就是这样发现了灌木丛。他就是这样发现的。因为当时的情况是，为什么克里德会在拐角处？我们当时想，那一刻你意识到，等等，我们怎么证明克里德去了灌木丛后面？我觉得这太搞笑了。我们觉得这太“克里德”了。所以我很喜欢。我还喜欢帕姆告诉迈克尔他必须下来，因为她有礼物要给他。他总是相信她。你知道吗，珍娜，我觉得很有趣，因为当我再次看这一集时，我一直在想凯伦在哪里？吉姆和帕姆在这一刻似乎在一起。他们正在弄清楚
out what Michael's up to and sort of brainstorming how to help him. And where is Karen? Right? Well, you are not the only person who was curious about that, Angela. We got mail on that. Oh, yeah? Kara Bailey, Rachel Ross, Maggie June, Sarah Hamilton, and Megan Womble all asked, where is Karen? Yeah, why is Jim only standing with Pam and talking with Pam? And then we don't see Karen again until the end of the episode when she's on the other side of Jim standing behind him. Yeah. I went to the script, Ange, and there is a whole plot for Karen that is not in this episode. You know how Karen earlier in the episode, she has that line where she says, wow, I do not know the people in this office like I thought I did. Yeah, because she's losing all the bets. She's
迈克尔在搞什么鬼，并商量如何帮助他。凯伦在哪里？对吧？好吧，安吉拉，你不是唯一一个好奇的人。我们收到了关于这个问题的邮件。哦，是吗？卡拉·贝利、瑞秋·罗斯、玛吉·琼、莎拉·汉密尔顿和梅根·沃布尔都问，凯伦在哪里？是的，为什么吉姆只和帕姆站在一起，只和帕姆说话？直到剧集快结束时，我们才再次看到凯伦，那时她站在吉姆的另一边。是的。安吉，我查了剧本，凯伦确实有一整段剧情没有出现在这一集中。你知道凯伦在这一集早些时候说过那句台词吗？她说，哇，我并不像我想象的那样了解办公室里的人。是的，因为她所有的赌注都输了，她在
betting wrong. And she has a talking head where she's like, I am like, I'm getting wiped clean here on these bets. I don't know everyone. Yes. So they have this whole plot for her where she's down in the parking lot and she's on a mission to get to know people better. So she's starting conversations with different people. She's got a little side conversation with Oscar. So I think that's why she's not standing by Jim. But those scenes are not in the deleted scenes, right? They are not. I watched the deleted scenes and that Karen runner is not in it. Well, one thing I did find that I thought was really fascinating and I loved this. I'll share it with you guys. And it's about the Jim Pam parking lot sort of story. In the DVD commentary, BJ said he talked
下错注。她有一个访谈镜头，她说，我简直是在这些赌注上输得精光。我不了解每个人。是的。所以他们为她安排了一整段剧情，她在停车场，任务是更好地了解大家。所以她开始和不同的人交谈。她和奥斯卡有一段简短的对话。所以我认为这就是她没有站在吉姆身边的原因。但这些场景不在删减片段里，对吧？确实不在。我看了删减片段，凯伦的那段戏不在里面。好吧，我发现了一件我觉得非常迷人且我很喜欢的事情。我要和你们分享。是关于吉姆和帕姆在停车场的那个故事。在DVD评论中，BJ说他曾和
to Greg and Greg was talking to him about Jim and Pam in this scene. And he said, I sort of see them as a couple that had been together for a long time and they'd had a child together. And that child and that child is Michael. And, you know, they're no longer together. They've moved on. But like oftentimes divorced couples who have kids when there's a crisis with their child, they work together to help their child. And they sort of have this shorthand with one another when it comes to their child. And Karen would not have known any of that history or Michael the way they know Michael. And so it made sense that Jim and Pam would be working together to try to make sure that Michael doesn't do something really stupid. And if you think about it in that context, it makes perfect
格雷格谈过，格雷格和他谈到了这一幕中的吉姆和帕姆。他说，我把他们看作是一对在一起很久并生了一个孩子的夫妻。那个孩子就是迈克尔。而且，你知道，他们已经分开了。他们已经向前看了。但就像许多有孩子的离异夫妇一样，当孩子遇到危机时，他们会共同努力去帮助孩子。当涉及到他们的孩子时，他们之间有一种默契。而凯伦根本不知道那段历史，也不像他们那样了解迈克尔。所以吉姆和帕姆共同努力确保迈克尔不做傻事是合情合理的。如果你在这种背景下思考，这完全
sense. And also the fact that Pam is like, I have a present for you. That's very parent mode, right? Come inside. I've got a treat for you. Stop doing what you're doing. I love hearing what BJ's thought process was when he was writing these scenes, because something I really appreciated about them was that Pam and Jim were not laughing about this. No. This was not a joke to them. They when they realized what Michael was doing, they come together very seriously to help him. This was also was not flirty. This was not a flirty moment, but instead really highlighted their bond. Yeah. And just the fact that instantly the two of them knew what Michael was up to. And, and it's like everything else didn't matter. It didn't matter that they had hurt feelings over
说得通。而且帕姆说“我有个礼物给你”，这非常有父母的样子，对吧？进来吧，我有好东西给你。别再做你现在做的事了。我喜欢听BJ在写这些场景时的思考过程，因为我非常欣赏的一点是，帕姆和吉姆并没有拿这件事开玩笑。不。这对他们来说不是笑话。当他们意识到迈克尔在做什么时，他们非常严肃地聚在一起帮助他。这也不是调情。这不是一个调情的时刻，反而真正突显了他们的羁绊。是的，仅仅是他们俩立刻就知道迈克尔在搞什么鬼，这就够了。就好像其他一切都不重要了。他们对
Roy, over Karen, over everything that has happened between the two of them. None of that mattered. All that mattered was getting Michael off the roof safely. And that's what happens. That's what that's what happens in real life. You put everything aside for your child and you work together. And, and I loved that little piece of backstory between Greg and BJ. Me too. Well, it's ultimately kind of Darryl that gets Michael to come down. I mean, Darryl has this great line where he's like, no one is braver than you. You have to wake up every day and be you, Michael. It's so brave. I couldn't do it. I couldn't do it. I mean, like, it's like the dig that Michael doesn't understand. And he just takes it so earnestly like, thank you.
罗伊、凯伦以及他们两人之间发生的一切感到受伤，这些都不重要了。唯一重要的是让迈克尔安全地从屋顶下来。这就是发生的事情。这就是现实生活中会发生的事情。你为了孩子把一切都放在一边，然后共同努力。我喜欢格雷格和BJ之间那段小小的背景故事。我也喜欢。好吧，最终是达里尔让迈克尔下来的。我的意思是，达里尔有一句很棒的台词，他说，没有人比你更勇敢。你每天醒来都要做你自己，迈克尔。这太勇敢了。我做不到。我做不到。我的意思是，这就像是迈克尔没听懂的挖苦。他只是非常认真地接受了，说谢谢。
And Darryl's like, you brave heart. And Michael's like, I brave heart. Yeah. And that's what got him off the roof. Darryl, Darryl believing in him, got him off the roof. And the episode ends with Michael having a talking head where he says, you know, sometimes you have to do crazy things to show the danger in an office, but he saved a life today. And it was his own. Yeah. And you know, he asked, like, is he a hero? Is he a hero? He can't really say, but yes. Well, and then we have this tag, which I love. It's Stanley. He walks out to the parking lot and it was his car that they bashed up. Like Stanley needs an excuse to hate Michael more. Oh my gosh. Exactly. Now, I do have to point out, Angela, that this watermelon all over the car was clearly
达里尔说，你这个勇敢的心。迈克尔说，我勇敢的心。是的，这就是让他从屋顶下来的原因。达里尔，达里尔对他的信任，让他从屋顶下来了。这一集以迈克尔的一个访谈镜头结束，他说，你知道，有时你必须做些疯狂的事情来展示办公室里的危险，但他今天挽救了一条生命。那是他自己的生命。是的。你知道，他问，他是英雄吗？他是英雄吗？他不能真的说，但确实是。好吧，然后我们有这个片尾彩蛋，我很喜欢。是斯坦利。他走到停车场，他们砸坏的正是他的车。好像斯坦利需要一个理由来更讨厌迈克尔一样。天哪。没错。现在，我必须指出，安吉拉，迈克尔在屋顶上时，车上满是西瓜，这在所有场景中都清晰
visible through all of the scenes while Michael was on the roof. And we had a lot of people write it and say, how did Stanley not notice this? And I can only say because what was happening on the roof was so compelling that we were all just looking up the whole time. And maybe that's why we didn't see this watermelon. Well, I wonder if that's why the deleted scene, which it's not even on the DVDs, but there was a scene where Mindy saw a busted up watermelon and like she thought it was a corpse and she freaked out. Oh, there's all these deleted scenes, guys, from this episode, many that aren't even on the DVD. Speaking of deleted scenes, before we wrap up this episode, Jenna, we did get some fan questions about a scene I was in that was deleted. Courtney Klein,
可见。我们有很多观众写信说，斯坦利怎么会没注意到这一点？我只能说，因为屋顶上发生的事情太引人注目了，我们当时一直都在往上看。也许这就是为什么我们没看到这个西瓜。好吧，我不知道这是否就是为什么那个删减片段（甚至不在DVD上）里，有一个场景是明迪看到了一个被砸烂的西瓜，她以为那是尸体，然后吓坏了。天哪，这一集有这么多删减片段，伙计们，很多甚至都没收录在DVD里。说到删减片段，在结束这一集之前，珍娜，我们收到了一些粉丝关于我参与的一个被删减场景的问题。考特尼·克莱恩、
Alice Chan, and Maria Malick said, Angela keys Andy's car. Why does she do it? Is it because she despises him that much for getting Dwight temporarily fired? How many takes did it require and did they need to fix the car each time? So yes, this is in the deleted scenes on the DVD. Listen, my character holds a grudge and Andy messed with Dwight. Angela is not going to forget it. She doesn't care if he's been to anger management. He's on her list now, lady. He's on her list. So in the way we did this scene, it was really great. Phil Shea gave me like a key chain set of keys. But the way I held it, there was this one sort of piece that stuck out and it was basically a wax stick. And when I walk around and I do that whole line, I'm really doing that. But I'm
爱丽丝·陈和玛丽亚·马利克问，安吉拉为什么要划安迪的车？是因为她因为安迪导致怀特被暂时解雇而那么鄙视他吗？这拍了多少次？他们每次都需要修理车子吗？是的，这在DVD的删减片段里。听着，我的角色记仇，而安迪招惹了怀特。安吉拉是不会忘记的。她不在乎他是否去过愤怒管理中心。他现在在她的名单上了，女士。他在她的名单上了。所以我们拍这一幕的方式真的很棒。菲尔·谢给了我一串钥匙。但我拿钥匙的方式，有一个突出的部分，基本上是一根蜡棒。当我走来走去说那句台词时，我确实在做那个动作，但我
basically drawing that line on with this sort of special wax stick. And it looks like I'm keying the car, but I'm literally just drawing a line around it. Whoa. Yeah. I would have never imagined. Isn't that cool? Yeah. And then they would just erase it. Then they would just wipe it off. Oh my gosh. That's so cool. Yeah. And it obviously, you know, it's a spy shot. It wasn't close up. So it was really easy to sort of cheat that and sell it. Wow. I know. Well, guys, that was safety training. Yes. And you know, not to be Debbie Downer here, but I just know how scary being that depressed can be. And I know this episode, we talk a little bit about depression, but it is real. And it can really take hold of you. And I just would want anyone listening out there to know
基本上是用这根特殊的蜡棒画出那条线。看起来像是在划车，但我实际上只是在周围画了一条线。哇。是的。我从来没想过。这不是很酷吗？是的，然后他们就会把它擦掉。他们就会把它抹掉。天哪。太酷了。是的，而且显然，你知道，这是一个间谍镜头。不是特写。所以很容易作弊并把它演出来。哇。我知道。好吧，伙计们，这就是安全培训。是的，你知道，我不想在这里扫兴，但我知道抑郁症有多可怕。我知道这一集我们谈论了一点抑郁症，但它是真实的。它真的会控制你。我只是想让任何正在听的人知道，
that you're not alone and that you're loved. And my nephew suffered from depression and we lost him to it. And I'm so sorry. I didn't anticipate I'd get this emotional. But I just want you to know you're not alone and that people love you and that you are valued. And if you are suffering from depression, there are places that you can call if you feel like you cannot talk about it with your family or friends. And guys, we have the phone number for the American Foundation of Suicide Prevention. And we want to take a minute and give that to you, Angela. Yes. It's 1-800-273-8255. Or you can text TALK to 741-741. And that's the American Foundation of Suicide Prevention. And you know, this happened a few years ago in my family. And what I wouldn't give to be able to talk
你并不孤单，你被爱着。我的侄子患有抑郁症，我们因此失去了他。我很抱歉。我没想到我会变得这么情绪化。但我只是想让你知道你并不孤单，人们爱你，你是有价值的。如果你正患有抑郁症，如果你觉得无法与家人或朋友谈论它，有一些地方你可以打电话。伙计们，我们有美国预防自杀基金会的电话号码。我们想花点时间把它告诉你们，安吉拉。是的。是1-800-273-8255。或者你可以发短信TALK到741-741。那是美国预防自杀基金会。你知道，这几年前发生在我家里。如果能和我的侄子谈谈，告诉他我们有多爱他，我愿意付出一切。
to my nephew and tell him how much we love him. And anyway, I didn't mean... This was a hard episode for you to watch. It was. It was a hard episode. It was. Even though there are so many wonderful things in this episode, just wonderful, funny, hilarious moments. It was a little difficult for me. And I just wanted you guys to all know that you're loved. All right, guys. We'll see you next week. Okay. Love you guys. Love you. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Irwin, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubelko. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com.
总之，我不是故意的……这一集对你来说很难看。是的。这是一集很难看的剧集。是的。尽管这一集里有很多美妙的事情，非常美妙、有趣、搞笑的时刻。对我来说还是有点困难。我只是想让你们都知道你们是被爱着的。好了，伙计们。我们下周见。好的。爱你们。爱你们。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由欧文、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制片人是安斯利·布贝尔科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。如需无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。
For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如需Stitcher Premium的一个月免费试用，请使用代码OFFICE。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。